welcome to podcast ville the Church of
what's happening now is brought to you
by turkey listen Thanksgiving is a time
to express gratitude and recollect on
what you're truly grateful for it's also
time when you invite your live family
members and say all they eat up all your
food and they blow up your [ __ ]
bathroom with that post-meal shits this
year make sure when your family shits
your house they leave with a clean ass
get a toshiba day for $69 with a
risk-free 60 day trial we enjoy what are
you talking about the days are back
[ __ ] that's what I'm talking about
there's no need to walk around with a
stinky [ __ ] on the [ __ ] up monkey
and if you dig this stinky this will
also help the helmet also go - hello -
she com use the code Church and we're
gonna give you 10% off your order
but listen you could be a filthy [ __ ]
animal all year might be a filthy
[ __ ] animal throughout the [ __ ]
holidays watch that ass comb your hair
do something your filthy [ __ ] first
thing you do is start with hello - [ __ ]
calm use code Church and get the 10% off
because change starts from within from
within
it starts from washing you [ __ ] then
you get confidence how you can walk
around with a bikini on you understand
me
no no hello - she's calm right now and
take a peek at the best bidet in the
business portable to boot if you got a
stinky ass and you want to travel bang
take it with you to the hotel you can
keep your little muffler [ __ ] clean
throughout the whole Jingle Bell process
all right hello [ __ ] Tom right now
leave check this [ __ ] meal are you
[ __ ] kidding me that's tile you got a
party started I'm saying you want to
play that shitty music you can listen to
all your life and that's why you stuck
with shitty friends and flies and [ __ ]
you gotta start your bodies off with
this song play that funky music white
boy Rick Ramos the movie [ __ ]
intrapreneur connoisseur this guy knows
more about movies than you'll have a
[ __ ] dream of knowing and my main man
the Christ killer it's this hard time of
the year you can knock on his door
there's no Halloween ting is your fire
Jesus is coming Jesus is dead and he
ain't coming back instead I think I get
the five dollar bill why am i giving up
five dollars because you Jewish it's
good luck you give somebody a fin we
also have a beautiful guest in the
studio over here [ __ ] apprentice
learning the podcast game name my dear
friend and that's it Rick Ramos a
[ __ ] pleasure to see you know it's a
thrill to be here why would you turn the
editor 43 Jesus goddamn [ __ ] I came out
here I was 24 24 I'm been you know even
if anyone is 19 19 years Jesus Christ
you know else would you have done this
this [ __ ] sentence I don't know what
the [ __ ] I don't know I don't know what
the hell else I can do a nice boy you
went to Chicago yeah you were a little
right the world on fine yeah I started
drinking with the Koreans and got all
[ __ ] up that's what went to the
[ __ ] dark place I just decided I was
gonna be I was gonna dedicate myself to
movies and that's what it is you know
it's crazy that we're very tight we have
a couple bonds because of the comedies
yeah we have bond because with dear
friend that passed on my birthday
anniversary ten years yeah nobody
remember that little candle I [ __ ]
blew some cigar smoke at a picture even
saying the refreshing the spirits and
[ __ ] she was beautiful I laugh about it
once a week store I still sit tango oh
my god if she would have been around my
daughter she would have called her a
bunch of [ __ ] no yeah [ __ ] and said
stuffing and there's nothing I could've
done cuz that's the way she was I judge
always I just remember I would be it
would be two o'clock in the morning I'd
be in my place I'd have to teach
kindergarten the next day and the
[ __ ] phone would ring and I knew two
o'clock in the morning that's her I pick
it up and she was like put it on Jerry
Springer and there's a giant fat lady
with our really tiny skinny guy who's
her boyfriend and we would just spend
the next hour laughing our asses off
screaming into the phone as they showed
this fat lady on her honeymoon in Hawaii
trying to a parasail and [ __ ] like that
and she was just [ __ ] ridiculous she
was she was the hardest friend that I've
ever had you know what I mean
I loved her and couldn't stand her at
the same time I'll never start a day
my wife yeah let me should call the
house of mastery in the morning and I
was in the bathroom doing blow hiding
then the phone kept ringing and ringing
and ringing and my wife picked it up
Marilyn goes [ __ ] and my wife just
look at me because it's for you and the
next morning my wife's at me yeah we've
been dating like maybe four months
these people the quality call you
[ __ ] for one the morning and it
was her she call you four in the morning
[ __ ]
what are you doing with the [ __ ]
snorting coke look another window you
gotta wake up everybody including the
[ __ ] cats call me tomorrow and the
husband Dave was great no I miss him
it's funny because I didn't go to
Ralphie's memorial because of what I
hire actually Marilyn's memorial you've
acted perfectly with hidden I go I I
hate those events because my temper yeah
and I always go off and I knew if I went
to Ralphie's I wasn't I go off on
somebody yeah and I kept thinking about
Maryland and Maryland is the one that
drove me to Ralphie's Marilyn Martinez
was responsible for him to do some meter
ralphing may because Marilyn called me
and said what are you doing are you home
alone why are you home alone Ralphie may
is staying with joy Medina over at Alex
goes oh yeah you live then I'll I lived
there for about a year yeah okay I can
goddamn it doesn't look good to I look
at her too and he goes he cooked
yeah it Ralphie make cooked a bunch of
food go over there and I was like a
Ralphie May the fat kid in Texas I don't
know I don't know him and they go go
over that and I won't know what it was
like Thanksgiving yeah something weird
and Ralphie cooked a [ __ ] spread yeah
you know it was his first la Spradling
Ralphie came down later and he was a fat
dude that's funny but I'm also going to
teach you [ __ ] how to cook yeah
and he made this phenomenal spread and
that's what I became he broke the futon
yeah it was a futon never wrote that
full-time and we became dear friends you
know from that thing I went over there a
holiday and he made me feel like [ __ ] in
I wasn't the deadbeat that I was guy had
a lot of heart man and he you know he
wanted to open up his home to everybody
because he liked the company you know
while he was at home with us cuz then
from Joey's Doug Stanhope had an
apartment on a cursed farm that was rent
control for six hundred and twenty
dollars geez if you go two blocks down
from Curtis Island 7-eleven will look up
yeah Doug Stanhope still the man that he
owns that apartment he really don't
rents it he sub leases it or but it
still his he'll never give it up it's my
little 600 miles in Hollywood inthis got
a garage oh [ __ ] so his friend and I
think it's Andy and rest'
I think that's the guy had an apartment
on Schrader
mm-hmm no no wherever the [ __ ] wouldn't
Ralphy moved ended up moving here that
was originally Doug Stanhope's buddy's
apartment then it moved to Alaska
so Doug Stanhope would just go over and
have parties near reasons and crazy [ __ ]
when he was dating Joe at the rehearsal
I wouldn't find them so he ever had that
department has affected another
apartment so they wouldn't find him
mm-hmm that's where he would disappear
that so it was two blocks away so he
lived on curse on Sierra Bonita was
Mitch Hedberg yeah and Nick the pollen
and then the next block was this kid
whatever once he left Doug told Ralphie
he could stay in there temporarily until
this kid came back as long as you paid
rent yeah so that was the deal the kids
said get so now Ralphie ended up in our
neighborhood which was that Nick can
normals guys and I lived on Vista via
Josh wolf no that's how I met Ralphie
it's real Marilyn Martinez I think I
spent more holidays with Ralphie and
Marilyn Martinez in all those years and
I did one year we went up then we ate
the mushrooms and we gave Milan the
mushroom and I ate the bag and I went
down and the whole room was purple and
she kept telling me Joey
this room is [ __ ] purple and I go ID
you telling me
was on stage you talking to the wrong
[ __ ] dude but I miss Marilyn it was a
magic though man she was just like she
was like a force of nature and I you
know I saw him roll with her oh yeah I
remember her calling me in that [ __ ]
town Corpus Christi we needed a Mexican
drug dealers bar poop and and they paid
me in her well and then we went up to my
hotel and she called me like an hour
late you enjoyed did he give you coke I
go no you what she's looking for you
he gave me like an ounce of coke and
he's looking for he wants to give you a
bag of coke too
I said let me call you right back
Pope from the owner and then what the
bat-signal sky I gotta find this
[ __ ] there's weekly in Milan got
quite doing all those Mexican lives
together yeah yeah we were going to road
together did you know our dealer at the
time huh did you know he was a drug
dealer already we had no idea all those
gigs in South Texas
all those gigs in those days it was
crazy because they put you in Maryland
together cuz you were the two dirty is
dirty out there I'm excited to follow
either yeah so they just said put him
together yeah me her and Jeff Garcia
would go on yeah and she was like her
little son I got yeah but I know forget
Lee you were the Duggar okay like honey
I had to go somewhere one time I liked
San Antonio for a one-night and I wasn't
into this I'm not hip to this even today
I learned from people you know you go on
the road when you bring your clothes you
bring your toenail polish right you blow
dry this [ __ ] showed up in her room
with a cooler the size of this table her
and a husband were carrying it in like a
body from the airport
no they built ride a wood drive
everywhere they drove every everywhere
if you had to go to Jersey that would
meet you in Jersey they way you got off
the plane they were [ __ ] pulling up
they'll pull it up and they'd have a
cooler
well I'm a mother exaggerate it was half
the length of this table was one of
those old they glued together the red
with the red yeah yeah yeah we carry it
into the room and in that bag like
that's how they save money I never knew
about saving money like there were a
couple that were rich and they were
but if they were proud to be frugal
because they shared with you so when
that thing was 2,000 pounds worth of
food tamales peanuts licorice [ __ ]
soda now diet sodas waters that chic or
you know Joey come on over to my room we
have snacks and you go over there and
you felt you felt the wind like I was
talking about Kentucky last night help
people that's what you thought like yeah
like they smuggle drugs with them on
this road trip and they were sharing
them with you she had the biggest heart
in the world she was just like she loved
and cared I mean she would lose it on
you but goddamn when she when her heart
was there I mean there was this uh she
called she visited me in Phoenix when I
was when I was visiting my parents and
you know like with you calling and
yelling [ __ ] into the phone
I wasn't home the phone the phone rings
my dad picks it up my oh man sounds like
me on the phone he's like hello and she
goes baby [ __ ]
and my dad just pauses for a minute
girls yeah baby [ __ ] not here
right now
this is daddy [ __ ] and she was
just like um um I'm just looking she was
[ __ ] great they met her later that
night she dug a hole even deeper for
itself she was like how I called him
baby [ __ ] because we have a friend
Joey Diaz and he's he's [ __ ] and
and David is telling her to shut the
[ __ ] up you know yeah she didn't give a
[ __ ] she was she was wonderful you know
and and it was like she she was my first
friend in that way yeah when the Latino
loco slam flew me in from Seattle to
showcase here and I populated the money
and just drove with my friend Rob long
way around long and Ruxin asleep offered
the money they gave me for the flight in
the hotel and I still might a is
something I'm gonna tell you where I
stay
we're just maybe four blocks from here
for me right this office when I first
came to LA this showcase for Latino
laughs festival I stayed close to the
Japanese restaurant we went to the
Japanese restaurant when they jump up
and down
Lancashire yeah what's the name of that
place I don't sit this oozy place yeah
yeah the sushis our referee bet like
that it's terrible yeah but they jump on
the table and they and they they they
[ __ ] the waiters karaoke on the table
you never took your mother Natalie no
I've heard I've heard about it but
there's a weird like there's a only
couple seedings new always at the way
show we didn't see the long and have
that like this [ __ ] yeah I went there
the first time that was my first dinner
in Los Angeles and then we stayed by the
YMCA in between those things the guy I
still see him his name is Cal he was a
longtime writer on MADtv and I see him
at the Y still today
once he I bump and his kids go to the
YMCA so I bump into him that but that's
where I stayed the same neighborhood
that's what's so weird yeah you don't
get you don't ever get away from it you
know when I went down to Hollywood and I
was at the piano a fact I was standing
there [ __ ] my pants on with a laugh
factory for Latino on a Monday night
1996 yeah 96 97 so around there and she
came up to me she generally the answer
I'm from Denver Colorado Springs oh
that's what bonded the two of you be is
that cop suckered drove you drove both
of you guys crazy
he treated you like [ __ ] he wouldn't
give you the spot right he would tell
you you guys are too dirty
you were young comic so you kind of took
it seriously and the bottom then I and
then he did a dirty show anyway okay so
the first year Latino laughs Esther will
belong to the dead comic who God bless
his soul Greg Geraldo okay it was a
setup for Greg Corrado Greg Corrado got
the special and the TV show from the
Latino life vessel so the second year
grew bigger yeah so his tentacles
reached out mm-hmm Swami's [ __ ] in
Seattle I'm onstage ain't bothering
nobody night before Thanksgiving we're
doing a big show me Josh wolf Gavin
Brody will paint him a new you know
whoever Cali Moran we're doing this huge
show and after the show Ron Reed comes
up to me with amen Jeff Valdez in the
audience he wants to talk to you so he
was you're perfect for my show
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba ba-ba-ba pop pop pop okay
pop pop pop off my pop will love you
we're gonna fly you down there
I call you he called but it was five
months later yeah and he they flew me
down I came down to the showcase that I
was first
they don't believe her yeah the really
[ __ ] Monday night well
so I died a bag of dicks now I got back
in the [ __ ] car I drove back to
Seattle forgot I wasn't you know it was
here first time I didn't really expect
anything but I didn't my feelings were a
little hurt yeah your feelings get just
a little hurt and then I just went back
to the drawing board and then they
called again in the second year yeah and
they wanted to tape this time mm-hmm and
I went to all extents like I borrowed
money to put this tape together yeah and
I sent it and they signed for it on a
Wednesday and on Thursday my manager
called whatever run really never managed
I was still in Seattle and they said no
Kendall too dirty for our festival if he
cleans up next year we'll take a look
the situation is sped up I move here
yeah I meet my own me Maryland collect
Latino laughs faster each Oh case we
showcase at the comedy spill when the
guy ran Latino levels and Sunday nights
and he made you wear a suit at a time
oh yeah yeah if it's Joey Diaz they
pulled me over I had to go to that
secondhand store on Melrose and buy like
a tuxedo and [ __ ] like a white shirt so
the showcase comes up they showcase us
they love us the only problem with too
dirty yeah
will they showcase you again Monday
night at the hotel Oh laughs factor huh
Monday night mere Marilyn go down there
they showcase us again now guys I'm
telling you about you being a young
comic you're not gonna become a
millionaire or to be a star you're just
looking for the first step you just want
to shot I just want the shot okay guys
so I show up for the second show this is
the third year in a row I'm showcasing
now they told me I'm too dirty to work
my set clean so I cleaned it up as much
as I could I took all the [ __ ] out of
it and anything in that range out of it
I think I think I said his [ __ ] and they
said no no [ __ ] okay which was crazy
because it was Showtime okay and then we
went back to [ __ ] the Comedy Store
and they showcased us again and they
said we'll still don't know me and
Marilyn were flung and livid and then we
ended up going to the improv I'm like
I'm Wednesday night and they showcase me
and Marilyn and the rule is not one
[ __ ] curse word don't say not even
what Zak hell hell don't say nothing we
want the thing to be TV [ __ ] clean
and we worked it I mean guys you don't
know how hard it was
oh yeah to do [ __ ] seven minutes
spotless clean at that time it was
torture but I did it was deceitful II
was it gonna get me an HBO special no
that didn't matter I just wanted to be a
part of the festival bah bah bah okay he
strings us out to the week before or two
weeks before the festival then he
cancels me and Merrill he does no no go
this year but then the following week he
does something and I don't know how this
feels to you people but this is how it
felt to me he added a blue to show on
Saturday night in San Antonio the
midnight show at that time was a blue
show what this means is a triple light
show so they added that to the festival
and still didn't invite me in Maryland
that's a [ __ ] you that that's how I
would look at that I mean that there's
no way you know I mean this is a guy who
yeah he was [ __ ] with you guys so
once he said this wall went down on a
Friday I know for a fact that little
chubby Mexican how feelings were hurt my
feelings were hurt but I kept it
together
I knew the animal I was dealing with and
I knew how the attitude was gonna be
from now on with these [ __ ]
douchebags personally and I tell you
this right here on this podcast if
anybody knows we're talking I was not
mad at Pat buckles at all know I love
Pat buckles today more than what I did
back then so it might be and even though
I haven't seen him in three years I had
no beef with Pat bubbles at the time she
was the casting director of the Latino
laugh at the festival so for us to do
she made us do a clean set and then the
week before the festival a throw a
midnight blue on Latinos there and it
was three dirt clean comics working
there
which is not so I was over it like I was
over it that week it took me a night of
snorting cocaine and maybe bumping into
a victim and I was over it I never
repeated it to nobody I was not angry
nothing that doesn't even make sense
doesn't make [ __ ] sense now we go to
the comedy store Sunday night me and
Mallon giggle it off yeah we have a few
drinks we go up she goes home Monday we
go down there for the open mic who do
you think is down there walking around
like Johnny with Mambo jazz Valdes cuz
there was some type of music show yeah
across the street at the House of Blues
so he walked in there like a [ __ ]
mafia leader with some other with
somebody else they walked in there super
cool and you know what was it uh that
[ __ ] that always got the wasn't this
deal with uh I don't know I don't know
he walked in with like two other dudes
and he walked in a super cool and I
caught him coming out and I said hey man
so you added a [ __ ] dirty shell and
you didn't have us and he he he may he
said something guys I didn't know what
he said so I left her alone I wasn't
angry I just moved the [ __ ] Hannibal
I was dealing with and that was it yeah
now that was it a year later they're
talking about the Latino Laughs festival
my phone doesn't ring I'm happy boom I
got a call you're in the fest yeah no
showcase no nothing say what you want to
do what you want the damage was already
done so I know this [ __ ] is but
this is the funniest out all the stories
so he calls me one day remember he was
giving out TV show he put me on the show
with a little crazy kid him and uh her
and Armando I'm Monica Seal and yeah
they were they were like a bunch of
bunch of white kids in the module and
they had to survive down there right
that's who you know yeah I remember that
he paid Marilyn peanuts [ __ ] yeah he pay
Marilyn peanuts they sold this show I
got a call from him one day they want to
do something
and by this time you know you've had it
with some valley when you like I really
want good business with you
they call me for some I swear to god
they're like listen we'll give you $50
and I go you don't want me it's not even
about the $50 I could use that $50 more
than anybody right now
ain't working with you thinking I hung
up and they called back and I go what
would it take like he knew yeah that I
had this certain attitude about him
about me that I didn't want like that's
it I was over it you know what we're
even so what you came back and gave me a
Latino laughs festival like you tried to
make it up I still know the type of
person that you will hear so he gave me
and you know I never talk about money on
this show he gave me 50 bucks the offer
and when I told to go [ __ ] themselves
they called me back up and gave me a
thousand for the same thing and it was a
tape recording that's on youtube today
yeah remember they had CTV yeah it was a
show for CTV and somebody cut and it's
on youtube today
I don't see that it was like an
interview and they gave me a thousand
bucks which Jesus Christ that was the
car payment three-month I was the coat
deal I was behind the money the coke
dealer you know that was like [ __ ]
gigantic [ __ ] money in 2002 nothing -
yeah three thousand two or three so I
kept them a distance and then they
scheduled the big Latino Laughs festival
for downtown LA no Hollywood remember
the theater on on the bottom what the
one the yes I don't want the bomb dude
yeah and something forgot about that so
now they were charging $50 technics but
they were making offers that they would
send a car to come get you since it was
a festival they weren't gonna pay no
they don't dealers Lee and they weren't
gonna pay it but they'll give you a ride
there didn't you ride there no sound
this is way before where they had a car
service
and I kept saying though yeah like I'm
not doing it I don't care what money is
then they kept then they would throw
money yeah yeah okay
how about a hundred miles not really how
about 200 in a ride how about 225 in
around here's know what not really and
guess what happened the day of the show
George Lopez Rudy Moreno and somebody
else cancelled yeah as they knew they
knew this guy was robbing from the mail
woke up and go wait a second what are we
doing yeah we're doing a 5,000 seat
theater for free for the name of the
Latino laugh festival which means Jeff
Valdez his pocket so now they [ __ ]
lot they backfired on him so that was it
everybody was even now I remember that
everybody is even now [ __ ] everybody
everybody's even Jeff this cool bubble
buyers cool but then something else
happened and it was something with
Marilyn in him something about money at
the end he order for two shows and he
said the two shows weren't gonna sell
and I get you know what no you know when
people call you ever have that
girlfriend that keeps getting beat up by
the same boyfriend yeah and she calls
you every week I'm gonna leave him after
Marilyn oh yeah after ten years you
finally one day go you know what man
when you leave him call me and hung up
on him with one of those [ __ ] deal
yeah Marilyn had had it with him when in
that process Marilyn [ __ ] gets cancer
and then six months later she [ __ ]
died remember that so they have this big
thing for her now you know I mean I
don't want to go into details but there
was people there were certain people who
said they were gonna pay for her funeral
but if a certain other person was there
he wouldn't pay for the funeral and when
the guy showed up it got really [ __ ]
ghetto wish yeah so I came back from New
York which was this weekend I went to do
a benefit for a Hoboken Police
Department which they [ __ ] moved me
they hated me and then I had to do a
benefit oh my god it was in back is
there undercover cops I'm talking about
drugs yeah and they were making believe
like they didn't know what I was talking
about and I finally know you [ __ ]
about guys crazy or what you guys
thought more bloated I do knock it off
and then I did something for the high
school basketball team and then I came
back I stayed sober that whole week
weekend yeah the whole weekend something
was up in my world like I gotta stop
doing drugs and boom that sadly Marilyn
died I [ __ ] knew it
I gotta get the [ __ ] done thank God I'm
not getting high but I came home and
then that Tuesday I had to go to Kempo
karate in Silver Lake wherever I used to
go where the restaurant food that's when
used to
the brothers yes the brothers down there
and I [ __ ] what instead of going over
and I was pissed
that's how they know that the wake to
know I was pissed because I didn't go to
kung fu oh okay instead I went to the
church oh god yeah well that I remember
as I was getting in my car I saw Jeff
Valdez day and my demeanor changed no
you you were yes I got in the car I sold
that [ __ ] they're like a world
war yeah after all the [ __ ] you put us
through you have the audacity to show up
at the wake and I wait and I didn't say
nothing as I was leaving for people that
were like kinda enemies were walking it
yeah I didn't say a [ __ ] warning he
held it together that I got a funeral
yeah that was giving it to get back of
the funeral I went to the funeral I kept
it together but I left early yeah I
could feel the kiss of death
I can I can tell that you were pissed
yes I did see the kiss of death coming
over and I was sober for like five or
six days this was day number six I had
this snorted no coke somebody was gonna
die somebody was gonna die I had not
done drugs this was the longest I was
ever sober from the time I went to
prison six days and I was ready to crack
and I have all I wanted to do was take a
sleeping pill I was there I think in
those days I would drink the half of the
bottles of nyquil nice yeah - for me the
phone
that's the only way I could beat that
addiction in the beginning I would have
to get a bottle of nyquil and drink half
of it one let me have it the other so
I'd pass out good yeah
there's no way I'm gonna wake up at 7:00
in the morning and snort coke that's
never gonna happen so it would be
another night I would wake up and go
wolf and you'd be in count me out that
nyquil tonight so for a week I just
drank my cool to make me [ __ ] pass
out and that night I was I said you know
what I'm not gonna [ __ ] stay clean
there's an old hammer yeah but you
didn't clean you didn't [ __ ] up until
after the after the incident right no I
didn't [ __ ] up at all here's the deal I
[ __ ] said you don't wanna I'm gonna
go buy some coke and come home and
that's it
whoo-hoo the [ __ ] mic
I'm never gonna stay sober that's never
gonna [ __ ] happen and a friend of
mine called and she goes bro you gonna
Marilyn's thing and I was only go down
there yeah
and she'd understand what I was I didn't
want to tell this and if I go down I
must not coke yeah so let me not go down
there and that's not coke let me stay
here in my [ __ ] house huh and her
member I [ __ ] she does you have to go
you have to go you cannot not go she was
your friend you have to go and she put
me together now I was angry and on the
way there I stopped by the [ __ ]
Martell cartel woman and I bought a
grandma blow I said I'm gonna take some
blow this [ __ ] hell I went in
there and I'm gonna forget that I was
going in there was a kid that kept
trying to do something like a project
well and he kept trying to call me and
there was no money involved and I didn't
have the balls to tell him leaving the
[ __ ] alone or that night at the bar
before I went into that room he was then
he said hey man I've been trying to call
you for more thing go get the [ __ ] away
from that I'm gonna be a shitty [ __ ]
thing all right and right there I knew
it I knew somebody was like it stabbed
the son I didn't know who I knew I was
angry I was angry about her dying
I was angry about not doing blow for six
or seven days I was angry about a lot of
[ __ ] you know and next you know I walked
in that room and there was food in the
back yeah I remember that you remember
they moved the tables around the main
room and there was food in the back here
and I said went back there to get
something I saw Jeff Valdez again guys
who and my temperature went from zero to
60 doing everything bad that ever
happened the minute my life was about to
go down and I remember walking out and
going to the ball and I never drink at 8
o'clock at night especially without a
line of coke I went in there I got a do
is on the rocks
I like drank it and I was so angry I
could feel that do was going into my
thumb like guys I don't know and it was
the manifestation of the sorrow yeah
that's all it was I was I was
manifesting Marilyn was our den mother
she took care of Samara ways we had
Thanksgiving wrong I need a place to
stay I mean she was there she was there
so it was just something
really weird but something happened that
September on a Sunday when she got out
of the hospital after she had all the
surgeries for cancer she was at her
house and there was neither tape of
documentary yeah some people over there
that was people that were not gonna know
but yeah we went over there they were
trying to shoot a documentary and I sat
next to him that little cancer bet it
was those Hospital bets yeah it was in
the front room I had a front room the
cats were there yeah the [ __ ] TV was
on and she was not in the room guys I
mean it was really sad like when you
could walk into a room and your best
friend is lying on the bed yeah but you
could see that something's not right and
we were talking about why you feeling
and she was telling me that if god help
her beat this that she would go on stage
and never be blue again that that was
her biggest mistake and that was her
biggest sin that she would never work
dirty again never say another word and
I'm waiting looking like a gold so I
never hit [ __ ] from me and she
looked at me like Stern like I'm not
[ __ ] around right yeah and that's we
were talking I've told you the truth as
we were talking we were talking about
some about well I'm gonna have another
surgery I'm Wednesday and then if that
works out I'm gonna come out and go to
this place over here and I got a big
[ __ ] tamale that's what I like that
she when she was talking to me that day
she was talking about food like I could
really go for a big [ __ ] pork taco
from around the corner over there yeah
in the middle of conversation she was
Joey you have to start like she just
said that I know where every my
everything started and I told me you
know what you're right
she doesn't know you have to stop
because God wants you to stop spoke and
I was like this ain't good man that's a
[ __ ] message she's never told me that
she used to hold my coke with that whole
Whitney Houston thing that's who had my
coat it was Marilyn I was giving her an
eight ball a day we're looking like 28
grams of the house or one [ __ ] time
and she goes when he gonna sell if I'm
not saying I'm saying
is for big [ __ ] party I see well what
type of party is this Joey you gotta
stop doing that [ __ ] but she never
really I come on McCall and then go and
bring me to talk what did I do it I'm
gonna [ __ ] do it
all of it you can't Joey what about
Terry no way binary so it's just weird
that this connection
it was Maryland Ralphie you know yeah it
was such a weak connection and now we're
here alone but used to remember her and
nobody call me nobody said nothing to me
about mountains 10th anniversary I was
creepy about the last few days just on
my own I found the picture and I put it
in my little [ __ ] spirit altar and I
got the little of a folder with her on
the you know where it's red with the
roses around her you want that red dress
that's where the red dress and you know
I I look at it every once in a while
he's the one that talked to sit the
Weight Watchers yeah she got us down
Jerry I went to lay watch the other
sandwich Waylon was one of his dress I
heard you standing out there and this
was when used to just loved to show your
balls I wrote you would you'd wear those
pants and they would just like she would
be talking and everybody'd be standing
around she'd be talking and the pants
would start slipping and slipping and
slipping and we're losing our [ __ ] and
all of a sudden she'll just look Oh Joey
like that [ __ ] thing away
Harvey Weinstein Janet she would say
some fucked-up [ __ ] to people we got a
ticket one night I mean we went we did
guys I gotta be a when you do comedy
sometimes you picked your friends and
you just start doing these gigs together
and the gigs suck but you have so much
fun cuz it's your friend and there's no
pressure gigs like Mike gigs now a
pressure game I got a produce guys those
impression gigs
no pressure gigs nobody gives a [ __ ] you
getting a quick hundred hours free drink
tickets and a dinner and you know the
man annuity you and her break-in Rudy's
balls you would live to break Rudy ball
got on there together and yes joy is
[ __ ] Rudy
I know was a guy that used to book the
Commerce Casino
he also booked the bar the Commerce
Casino is a gambling joint off the five
after five find out who that yeah it's
about 20 minutes from here to BARC it's
quick for me and Lee won a couple times
every time you go play and there you're
[ __ ] scared shitless
because it's really owned by like some
mob yeah it's how I know cuz my friend
is Filipino and she applied for a job in
there and she didn't take it yeah
they're [ __ ] savages oh I hope he
knows this she told me she wasn't this
is mob stuff and they got the best
Chinese menu yeah it's good they took
all types of food they're here of the
Asian but [ __ ] the Chinese food is
[ __ ] good down there and I don't go
down there you understand me that's how
it's [ __ ] up down there but he used to
book that room for the small yardstick
every Thursday yeah he was getting eight
thousand a week and he didn't pay three
commas miles yeah he would clean up
[ __ ] hilarious [ __ ] he would run this
other room the brave bull
they had like that's what he calls it
didn't she cause a riot in there one
time yes he called if this was a place
that had like built bull horns on the
walls [ __ ] and they had three rooms I'm
sitting here laughing but you guys know
I give a lot of credit about son if it
wasn't for Redeemer in those days I
wouldn't be it yeah because Rudy Marino
has in those days paid me every there
was a six-month stress that me and him
just had a mutual agree I'm coming down
for an answer and I would play whatever
room he had sometimes you'd have the big
room down there sometimes you'd have the
media room the big room had like a dead
moose of the thing I remember when it
was a Pablo Francisco 1997 and then he
had like him but his best room was this
back room and it looked like a wedding
room in the East Coast but it was a set
they had a set with flowers and stuff
like that around the stage and people
but this was a weird Mexican crowd and
Marilyn went up there one
nitin said some and the wife said
something and the guy threw a chair and
the other now this is Rudy Marino's baby
- no Rudy is to love him Rudy is a
gentleman he wears glasses he's by the
book he wants you to wear a certain
shirt and he would always break mine and
mouths balls until we basically told him
to go [ __ ] yourself watch we'll make it
work yeah don't be dirty don't be dirty
in people don't like when you're dirty
watch us and me and Milan prove to him
that they like dirty company we didn't
give a [ __ ] what he told us he wasn't
the comedy store guy he's a great timing
for anybody wasn't the [ __ ] time he's
taught and he wasn't gonna run our
careers
these are bars yeah this isn't [ __ ] a
church these are bars what are you gonna
bar to do to have a few drinks and
loosen up and look good for your friends
no he's like you gotta work clean and me
and man will go up on stage and he'd be
back there giving us the light like like
knock it off
and I wouldn't [ __ ] get off I would
stamp there for another ten minutes and
go [ __ ] crazy a bit
[ __ ] you [ __ ] suck my dick and
I would see him back there turning red
in the face of this [ __ ] but they'd be
laughing yeah any then we could come off
he's like Jesus Christ Joe you give me a
heart attack but its head that's some of
the dirtiest ever heard I know Rudy
they're [ __ ] laughing it doesn't
matter at all that matters so he went on
back and forth with us for about a year
he would torment me and [ __ ] Marilyn
so one week and he takes his Road gig
and that's the weekend Mary decides to
go up to the brain Bowl on a Saturday
night and have an argument with a guy I
will never forget this story I was not
event
I just heard there was chairs it's not a
[ __ ] legendary and there's eight
people on the floor wrestling and the
two wives are pulling each other's hair
and Marilyn's on stage like a narrator
like Joe Rogan [ __ ] bit the dala dala
dala [ __ ] so he says she got paid [ __ ]
Omaha Haven oh my god somebody this guy
Larry Omaha it's a brilliant having
great
writer he got hit and I guess he paid my
own you know rule even have him enjoys
palaces let me tell you something Sunday
morning 901 though she got things and it
was really Marilyn what happened brewery
let me tell you well and I told you
we're clean and then it wasn't cuz I was
daddy gonna do it that some guy threw a
chair they threw a [ __ ] chair who
done it she was she was a hurricane of
craziness she didn't care at the wild
coyote she started fights in there
remember just old some guy
she started making fun of this guy's
girlfriend she went back at him the
boyfriend said something and then she
was like you know what I thought you
were kind of cute I was gonna offer to
suck your dick but you probably just got
out of jail and it tastes like [ __ ]
we're all standing around like oh [ __ ]
we're all gonna get killed tonight you
know and David sitting there like [ __ ] I
was doing a gig with her this [ __ ] gig
in um Lubbock Texas someone heard I
don't know where the [ __ ] we were but
we're doing this gig and we get there
and Marilyn Alex Raimundo and I are all
sitting around bullshitting and she's
breaking our balls about how we're a
couple of [ __ ] and if we go to her
room she's got a strap-on and she'll
[ __ ] us both in the ass and she's just
saying all kinds of crazy [ __ ] right so
as she's doing this out on the patio
with with families and [ __ ] around right
so she goes into her room I go into my
room
Alex is in his room I get a phone call
maybe maybe seven minutes later she's a
Greek you got to come over here and help
me you gotta come over here no I was
like what the [ __ ] is going up and she
was like there was a guy next door who's
listening to us and he said that I could
come over then I could [ __ ] him in the
as with that strap I'm called David and
now he's mad at me because he's told me
about talking dirty
get her another room mover it was
[ __ ] great that's funny because I was
with her in the bowels of hell little in
Texas yeah
no disrespect that's the club Lee where
the DEA raided it but the first time I
went to that club I wore a Marilyn yeah
and they put us in the hotel they had a
pool and we were around the pool yeah
by somebody tried to break into a room
the [ __ ] here's 300 pound for for a
Marilyn this burglar didn't know what he
was doing this is gonna be the first
rapist in history I was gonna kick the
dog down and go I don't think so
he was gonna run out of there Marilyn
was 300 pounds with her sleigh in there
with a bag of [ __ ] chocolate three
different sizes like she was in
Yellowstone Halloween bags right she
would take him on the road with her and
that night she you go to her room and
she had all four bags on the bed wait
they haven't when it's not Halloween
time oh yeah oh yeah little ones for
little Chubby's like Marilyn justify it
each one is three points okay I [ __ ]
hate I listen don't [ __ ] say a [ __ ]
word all right I only ate two of each
that three points until I walk 40
minutes on the [ __ ] thing the machine
there my foot
they're turning purple Joey she would
have four different types of chocolate
sweets for for eight three other pounds
and the rapist was knocking down her
door and she's in the Fox she's playing
on the door the rapist is on the other
side he was an escaped convict out of
all the rooms in the hotel he decides to
break into my can you imagine breaking
on a jail for a piece of Martinez for
for a 300 pounds what would you do Oh
what the [ __ ] do you do take the first
bus man it's all on me this whole
weekend was crazy and when we've gone
for some reason she had a great wine to
promoters
promoters always called her from all
over the country I got it you know I
tell you guys how it is with comedy few
people are interesting when you get here
yes there's an upper montage economy
it's the Comedy Store The Improv the
Laugh Factory and they're all great
clubs and then you have a lower-end of
clubs in Silver Lake which is just Mars
and then one night is you get two
dollars no maybe a dream you'd be here
yeah maybe a bit you get nothing and
this is how it is for a few years but
the fight this is why I give credit to
these men little Mexican guys that's why
I've had them on the show from Willy -
Philippe all these guys did you hear
today 20 years ago
guys hustle nobody [ __ ] like these
guys yeah nobody gave them spot we think
Felipe did was doing the improv and all
this [ __ ] before Last Comic Standing no
Felipe and his buddy Willie and Jeff
Garcia I'm Rudy Moreno and all these
guys for all you guys are sitting there
in our town going I want to do comedy
but I don't know what to do well let me
tell you what these guys did yeah they
went to all those see little [ __ ]
gangster rooms where there's a
possibility of getting some respect
and they went in there and I'm telling
you and Rick knows Rick knows I believe
in my bones in those we made our bones
in those rooms because they gave you 35
bucks and these guys were such hustlers
they'd have three rooms in one night at
one time at one time I can honestly look
at all for you in the room and tell you
I was pulling on anywhere from five to
six hundred a week in 2001 in this town
I was pulling down six a little week
doing stand-up in this town that's
twenty four [ __ ] hundred a month you
know what you guys like Joey that's not
no money let me tell you something you
live in your dream 24 do you have an
apartment and receipt it with three
[ __ ] guys you make $150 car payment
and you pay back your student loans
you're good to go only he's got a drug
habit
unless you got a drug habit you can live
on 600 a week yeah if you live if you're
barely 20 girlfriends yeah and if you
don't do blow and if you could conserve
weed legal living in [ __ ] Sherman
Oaks with three other guys pay 850 a
[ __ ] month you know two bedrooms one
guy sleeps in the closet yeah that's
what you got a dress you got to start
off when those rooms went under not to
mention but 600 was also 10 spots guys
so what average is about $60 a spot I'm
I got tired you're working for your work
you're thriving for it and yeah gas is
included yeah so let's get something
straight it was 600 minus a yardstick
for gas $10 for parking
do you know it's that kind of stuff but
she had money coming in that means your
cooperation was always so Monday like
okay what's tonight last night I we last
night I would have a spot at the Laugh
Factory for money five bobtail but
before that spot or after that spot I
would go up to a Universal City on
Mondays
in a rubber room do the rhumba room for
40 but now and then Tuesday I would wake
up who do the Comedy Store even though
there was nobody there because it was
african-american night so the original
room would be dead yeah I was 15 bucks
and then somebody had a $40 room Casa
latina latina head of young black dude
and then somebody else had a lay that I
had a sapphire on to you where between
1575 there you go uh-huh so you had
Wednesday night was like oh oh Wednesday
was wile coyote wile coyote Wednesday
and Saturday with lolly this is a small
40 monthly burrito
yeah a [ __ ] good burrito a real good
burrito cotton Thursday you had the
Commerce Casino I still go back with
Gabriel booking the bicycle club a while
the small 30 final yeah in 1997 Jai
Brooks all these Latin comics built
their own underground network that even
stepped foot in the [ __ ] comedy
nothing they wouldn't even bother they
wouldn't even bother because they knew
they weren't gonna [ __ ] the only club
that gave them love was the last fact
and that Latin room still [ __ ] Rock
yeah it still does I remember it was it
was Chris Martinez Jeff Garcia ran it
for a while everybody had it at one
point and it was just like it was a
great room and it was a packed house and
they they [ __ ] lived for comedy The
Comedy Store didn't give us love The
Improv didn't give us love maybe you
might get something in Ontario or Brea
which were great rooms but they weren't
gonna give you [ __ ] it was they might
give you a Wednesday they may yeah it
was one else but none and you'd have to
paper the room it was a different
[ __ ] game but you know what I don't I
I thanked Rudy and all those you know
that's why I've had Willie on the
podcast multiple time he has a lead Bay
because when I got here they were
putting 40 hours a week in my pocket
here's a buck 60 because at the end of
the week it all went into a comb and add
it up at the end of the month and you
sit there at the end I'm gonna throw I'm
broke really not you aren't making an OK
living it's not [ __ ] you don't comedy
here here what are you expecting
god forbid you book a commercial oh my
god yeah booked a day on
[ __ ] TV show the scale 650 god dammit
I'm go for sushi but hell yeah I'm going
with sushi babe and you're gonna have a
good time you feel like I'm a human
being for a little bit
it's cool then there's months when that
is dick like there's months you look at
your schedule and there ain't ya dick on
that schedule like themes outright
called me a month ago you look man and
this is top being a professional comic
my whole December is wide open oh I'm
the make it look like a lizard that's
what it is to be a professional yeah
look at that you know you know what I
want to believe in the Lord I'm gonna
believe unless you gotta have faith in
yourself yeah and also the next thing
where you just start popping these gigs
and they were months when it be the 25th
yeah and I had no idea I was coming up
for rent money in six days
not a [ __ ] clue I don't think well
I'm gonna get evicted and lost in the 30
if you get a call for a Halloween game
they're paid exactly what the rent is
and they gave you a check which really
[ __ ] oh well [ __ ] it I'll take good and
[ __ ] I remember those days I never had
the faith to do that though I always had
the job I always had some shitty I was
doubles a substitute teacher at that
time it's in your blood
yes I was thinking about you tonight how
you never really I didn't have faith in
myself like that really and you know the
faith of not having a job it takes you
to the next one it does with what's the
what's the movie there there's a scene
in one of the anarchy movies I think art
what's our friend and [ __ ] now what's
our little friend what's our family
member down in it that's keeping things
on ice for us till January now then
Austin Bobby Sharon right okay crisp
his girlfriend put the clip up I'm gonna
put a clip up through Suns Anna here
what's inside yeah okay Sons of Anarchy
or was the with season of the black guy
what was his name the biker the black
biker gang boss no the other guy the one
that
they shot in the [ __ ] they shot him
in the thing when they told him to meet
they were gonna give up Trager I
remember his name I remember but Jax
tellers meeting with and see what comes
up okay
no but you're right though it was like
you know this is he's like this is no no
I know it's right no no I don't know I
always knew you had the talent I always
knew you had the balls we work together
a lot of times but the fear you a Comedy
Store trained you'll probably split
trains which means you have you went
through the seal program which means
that you really can't be scared you
gotta believe in yourself Jax teller
thanks mr. mayhem no no no oh no that's
a bad one plus son zanuck you season six
I think that's how season six start
everything he talks about that oh yeah I
don't remember no we can't go through it
no I can't no that's wrong yeah there's
a scene where he goes to see him you
know it's using pain to get the next
level that's what makes Kings out of men
it goes that's how you do it and that's
the same thing with what we doing away
in a way you have to put yourself
against the wall to really grab whatever
having you real close I would give you
beating us about another console yeah
yeah because and then you never saw it
in that way you saw it like I'm gonna
miss something and I get it listen man
going through life without insurance and
a bunch of things is a [ __ ] American
reality today it's a scary reality and
I'll look in the eye and I'll look me in
the eye and my little pal in the air
tell you the young grief I did some
movies and I'm grateful that I just
stand up but I'm grateful I got sag
insurance [ __ ] yeah okay I was not
cut out to have insurance I'm like I'm
never gonna have insurance I mean I was
just telling somebody I'm automatically
level to more than bank level true
because I've been sacked more than ten
years and I'm over 45 oh yeah so you saw
you're locked in yeah I'm locked in at
all I have to fight every month again
but I gotta face time the residuals
couple level two I still get them every
year I'm booked like yes star and then
they always give me that other respects
pay you twice yeah that twice makes me
level to see that's the thing that
always scared the [ __ ] out of me and
it's like what about when I got into it
I thought to myself well you can go to
one of two ways you can either go on the
road and bust your ass on those [ __ ]
cakes and [ __ ] games but by the time I
got here in 2000 and I would have been
it I would have been able to do the road
a lot of that [ __ ] had dried up so what
would end up happening is that now
you're paying for the flight they don't
know we want to put you up it's kind of
crazy and they're not giving you [ __ ]
and it's a feature in today's for eat
your world it's very tough like a lot of
times if it's a local thing if I could
fight for a feature I don't bring a
feature my own brand if I go on the road
20 weeks I bring a feature maybe six or
seven years because like there's a lot
of clubs that I lose a thousand bucks
bearing on the feature if I was single
and whatever but I got a four year old
yeah
I can't just lose a thousand bucks
because it's a hotel a week oh yeah
there's no more well for one I want I
want I found you don't want to give this
kid right you want me to really
embarrass you and tell you what they
want to give them and look him in the
eye and I can't let that happen
know why you came with me brother you
don't saying so I mean it's I want you
to be taken care of I want you to eat
good yeah you know when I go to
breakfast you go to breakfast and I go
to lunch you come with me when I go to
dinner we eat together you know Lee you
know how it is when we go to movies with
[ __ ] family it will corporation so
but you sit there at the end of the week
know Jesus
[ __ ] Christ they banged me out you
know because my hotel room is free so
you don't really know the rates yeah you
know and the contract where they put me
up I always go why they put me you know
me yeah I'm a simple dude
but the agency I'm with ass for [ __ ]
I'll buy pop its orbited because they
want an out now yeah I don't mind him
staying then oh my earrings am but that
room is creating and I'm like Jesus
[ __ ] Christ and I gotta give them was
gonna get their walk so I try to cover
his plane ticket look at the plane
ticket to again they're gonna raise the
price again because gas price is
something with oil again they're gonna
raise the price
see that's the thing and I and I said to
myself you know what I don't know how
funny I am because you know that and
when you're a comic you think you're
funny you're funny enough to get your
ass out on that stage and the laughs are
there but you're never quite sure
because you see how if you see they're
laughing at somebody else that you like
that [ __ ] ain't funny
but then there's this thing about it
where I'm like if I go out of town cuz
then I just got signed to my agency
how's it gonna look if if I can't go on
an audition because I'm I'm playing some
[ __ ] gig and [ __ ] in a Seattle or or
Texas or something like that they need
me here they don't they don't have me
here they're gonna drop my ass you know
and I booked just enough to keep my
agency interested in me so are you
looking right now I'm not booking but
they're sending me out a little bit by a
little bit I need if I if I were to
start booking something they would send
me out more but it's like it's so crazy
because the percentages have even gone
even though well you know I was telling
you about trying to get extra work extra
work pays anywhere between 114 to 172 a
day depending on whether it's new media
or it's a show that's on a network if
you go over time like I was telling
somebody I either want to do five hours
and get paid the eighth all I want to do
fourteen [ __ ] hours because a 14-hour
days gonna get you over $300 you know
and you never know when you're gonna get
Rick yeah yeah and when you could have
joined the army
yeah you remember yeah I'm a little
taste when you're 18 need to join the
army and be walking around when you're
[ __ ] 38 now in hindsight how old do
you know 443 how fast was it you became
38 after high school Joey I went to
sleep I was 25 I woke up hour 43
I have no idea what happened I serve
your young right man you listen to this
let me tell you so if you [ __ ]
confused and you really don't know and
this is from your uncle Joey I don't
watch out there were kind of [ __ ]
some fast-food joint it to your finger
it out try it yeah try the service
because let me tell you some guys 20 is
goes by quick yeah
listen to me you're my brother I don't
want your [ __ ] two years you gonna
quit your job 20 years ago you would
have been working full-time
yeah I know and that's the end of this
conversation this is why I tell people
you come out here it's all men on deck I
want you to get a job I appreciate that
you had an apartment yeah but at one
time in your life it's like there was I
worked with each guy last week from
Boston and home on a brothel huh bro
this guy had me back this wedding
[ __ ] both we this guy was so [ __ ]
funny we lost an accent it was just the
three men showing he was doing a half
hour I'm like how am I gonna follow this
[ __ ] they handled my boring ass oh man
material he's you know 41 he is
hilarious ended 50 minutes on Friday
night because I only did one show yeah
so I stayed for his first 35 minutes it
wasn't let you beat my smoke to join I
sat in the back or just the support he
thought I left but I watch dog he was
destroying them all the next night I
talk to him the way I'm talking to God
just let the guy go so what's going on
it's like I'm living in Boston I do all
the gigs Danny playing with cards when
Lenny Clarke I went down for him this
guy was a top-notch comic guys you know
he's a top
that's coming and I go what's going on
in Boston do you want allow I don't know
I'm still confused between that way and
as a dynamite guy as he was and as funny
as he was he was pissing his pants about
that thought yeah I go so what you mean
to tell me is you're this age you have
no kids no wife nothing holding you back
in Boston
you're a no man in life go for it
well I realized I was a nomad I always
had an idea I was a nomad but I didn't
want to believe it you never want to
believe you're a nomad you know what
your Nomad is that you're alone but the
reality is once they [ __ ] cut you
from your mother's and biblical cord
you're living alone you just had a
little help not you're on your own it's
a scary thought and that's all you you
just you never really you were scared
you wanted you wanted to make sure your
rent was paid yeah and there's nothing
wrong with that brother what's up buddy
no I mean it yeah it's just it's because
I made the jump it's scary it's you grow
up and it's you know it's not only that
you want to be successful but then it's
also especially living in LA there's a
lot of homeless people like it's not
that big of a like like that like that
there was a fear of mine that would have
made him shoot straight to the top you
think so I know so yeah I know so I want
you at one time in your life to have
your back against the wall to really
know what life's about
and that's when you [ __ ] figure it
out that's what they don't teach you in
a six [ __ ] year college okay I don't
care how many master's degree is when
you back yourself up in a [ __ ] wall
when I come to you when I go Lisa blah
blah blah blah blah blah and you after
ten years working at my [ __ ] lawyer
firm you come to me when they knew I
want to be a partner [ __ ] you
I'm the head you in this [ __ ]
don't you ever [ __ ] talk to me like
that you're a little Jew from [ __ ]
Boston you know whatever and now guess
what you're married to my friends over
here and she not beautiful and she likes
to go on vacations you
do your thing but you got to get out of
this guy's clutches you know what mama
needs a new pair of shoes you got a nice
feet and everything so guys what you
gonna open up your own while your phone
so you gotta go to your father's bar on
[ __ ] his life savings and go to your
mother and borrow her life savings and
come to me and come direct to him and
you go to Worley and let me pay
something that 18 months suffering five
years from now you're gonna be a
millionaire I'd rather you take that 18
months suffering and continuum than
somebody else's [ __ ] and that's all
we got to do here you haven't done right
enough
I want you better this time goddamn 19
years almost done right now you have
been going to the bank getting checks
people with a little Ramos
oh when did you shoot Latino payaso
swear that was 2006 2017 so the door was
open the door was no I thought it was
that I [ __ ] it up
and I love you and I and I held you and
I told you from the heart from the heart
I said you gotta take this chance and we
have nothing to lose listen I lost a
wife I lost the kid oh I knew that that
child was never done I knew I wasn't
gonna get invited to first for me and
then yeah I knew I wasn't gonna get
involved and I stood in plays and I
wasn't gonna get involved in anything my
life with her was five hours on
Wednesday and every other Sunday how
could he just stay there and take that
beating for the rest of my life have
become the local guy that's funny in
there hey we got a job in radio or I
could give it a shot for me and make her
you know something I want to do
something and dog that was a scariest
[ __ ] move I ever made and but I
learned from taking a chance from doing
being a Salesman yeah you know there's a
chant when you walk into a place yeah go
I guess what hey man you want to be a
Salesman yeah 90 days I'll give you
1,500 a month for 90 day
the average Joe goes way to seven like
850 a month that's a real world overtime
then only give me 1500 wear a shirt and
a tie
yeah and sell cause the first three
months are gravy it's 750 every two
weeks you know something you're in there
where than the do's and the outs well
that [ __ ] 90 day comes jack on the
15th of the month you haven't sold a car
and they give you 600 all draw just to
keep the lights on it on the 15 but you
gotta cash that out by the 31st then you
get paid on the fifth you gotta let your
- 600 Jack bless your dry cleaning your
gas they're just about selling cars just
by selling cars and once you start
selling cars and you start gaining that
confidence in yourself now you go you
know how it works you know at the
beginning of the months gonna be slow
you're gonna take three dog you're a
fighter you're gonna fake take the first
five days a month you only gonna work
your shift you only go to movies with
your buddy Lee he's your [ __ ] best
partner you're gonna get some blow you
know saying you're gonna go see nothing
[ __ ] at allmovie but that on the
[ __ ] sixth you know your
[ __ ] gotta go to work and all
those lucky lose that come in now you
got to work 12 hour a day so all those
lucky lose that come in all those lucky
lose you got to press them a little bit
give them a card and stay on they gonna
buy a car within [ __ ] 72 hours
they're gonna run into a Salesman within
72 hours hopefully it's you when they're
come on the lot
I'm just looking for next year I don't
give a [ __ ] where you look all the time
you look for a car they'll be rocket
ships [ __ ] and we're buying a car today
you got to manipulate them to buy a car
collector and you know it's uh it's
salesmanship like what we're doing right
now isn't about who's the funniest guy
in the world there's a thousand funny
guys
your love is movies and I've always
asked just just do a [ __ ] routine
about movies have you got a routine
about movies you'd be real one of these
TV stations were picking out Mia and we
get assurances son you ever tell them to
do
I love you like a brother and I didn't
bring you in here to break your balls at
all no no you knew the situation I just
want people that are trying to get into
to understand that sometimes you have to
cut the umbilical cord and comedy with
your job and everything
at least give it a shot because that
will motivate you to become the comedian
who you're bound to become well that's
the thing that's the thing that always
scared me and it's the thing that that
really [ __ ] me up because you know
I've been alone for 20 years I've been
holdin to nobody you know I got no wife
ain't got no kids I don't you know
there's there's not a note I'm driving a
[ __ ] seventeen-year-old car but
there's always been that fear of you
know tomorrow it's gonna go right into
the [ __ ] and the reason that I've
stayed away for so long and I know this
is not this is not on you this is um
completely on me I felt ashamed I
honestly felt ashamed for for being
afraid and I couldn't face you for the
longest time you know and I knew you
still loved me I knew you cared yeah no
no I was worried about you for a while
that I was well I was in a dark place
for a while yeah we spoke about on the
film and I know you had a hard time
there
there's nothing ashamed about being
afraid
nothing ashamed about it as long as you
keep it in check well and promise
yourself that you're gonna do something
to take yourself out of that zone yeah
talk I live in fear I was telling my
wife that you know why I'm gonna just
diner over here I don't wanna put nobody
down yeah there's a diner across the
street from 7-eleven over there okay let
me break down this Center that's right
yeah you got hell 7-eleven over here I'm
[ __ ] what is this Magnolia and
Tujunga right that's every man for
myself there's toothless people there's
pimps there's [ __ ] it's a [ __ ]
nightmare
yeah my favorite is the one by the
police station and trust me that one
gets creepy people the police station is
50 yards away in my line lee-sia not
even happening we're not seeing creepy
[ __ ] in there night and [ __ ]
like that
you see him looking at Redbox but
aluminum ugh somebody they got an open
mic at the end of that
no she they got a Japanese restaurant
with what - what's the rating see and my
line I took Lee and he [ __ ]
questioned me
this guy wheat a [ __ ] horn from a
billy goat and he looked at me like
we're going in there yeah we're gonna
make sure dry cleaners on the 7-eleven
and a dry clean in the 7-eleven ooh I
took his chances at this sushi place I
went twice what was a man once my my
sometimes in a rush I couldn't yeah I
wouldn't I got the teriyaki chicken you
could tell Oh
this was not this was some [ __ ] huh no
no and the [ __ ] spicy tuna was the
ugliest spot as I was eating it I'm like
oh man I'm taking my chances a little
Mexican way and I look in the back he's
the cook he's everything when he picks
up the phone he makes believe he's Asian
[ __ ] hilarious hilarious
I wanted that twice nothing you know but
they have a sidewalk cafe a cafeteria
then like the last thing is an Allstate
Insurance office and a dumpster
well a dumpster right [ __ ] there
right Glee please so they don't think
we're crazy here's every week on that
[ __ ] Church page i he let Joey Diaz
stories how far is the dumpster from
where people man John in 40 feet you can
I've been at it I call them I call the
25 feet now before the dumpster there's
a comedy club yeah it's a State Farm it
says they form insurance but if you go
there Monday through Friday
and give humming it's comedy there's
five people BYOB do your own thing they
go there after the sushi club he lures
them in they come on in
ha ha then you gotta have a dry cleaner
a Russian guy I want to better get my
gear I can fix 50 bucks I go four
strings 50 [ __ ] balance I others then
they got something else in bartending
school I got the bartending school you
got to see the beauties that hang out
there Wednesday night happy hour $25 we
give it to you you try you see cars
crashing and next to that is the most
expensive gas station you will ever go
into if gas down the collison a mile
from their gas is 335 a gallon right
there it's seven 72 hours and people
faith yeah you know why it's next to the
police station so they bang out the
he's stationed for high prices and was
the police choice they caused it
yeah I think I like wanna flee 280 and
they charged a car and it's right off
the freeway right off the [ __ ]
freeways if you rob a bank and you're
running out of gas right there and then
you got Chandler 7-eleven that is the
bad one that's where the only got killed
in front of his wife that's where it's
it's [ __ ] Isis yeah
it's Isis you walk in there the music's
on Lee
I took Lee admin that I go Lee let's go
in there
this is worse than East Hollywood yes
this the channel of 7-eleven I took Lee
in there one night they had the full
turbines in full effect they had the
music on loud and there were like give
him white people to [ __ ] my Luke I
put it back like that flower like they
were eat yeah they wouldn't make I can I
go leave this is Isis about two weeks
later there was a stabbing they murdered
some money from that place homeless
person your homeless person came out
with a knife to stab the old and then
two weeks ago the [ __ ] shooter from
Las Vegas the brother was jerking off
the little kids yeah he was in the
building right next to at 7-eleven hey
[ __ ] here this that's a bad [ __ ]
area yeah I'm saying and then I have the
LA Luke yeah it's got the maluca bet you
gotta be careful over there I don't go
to that 7-eleven AI no more huh you know
that's a creepy sound lemon they got a
little spot there where people hide
where you make the rifle challenge it's
a creepy has a 24 hour long term I feel
like aaaa bros people but the reason why
I don't go to that diner crusty for
scent like him because the bus station
is down the corner okay any day but I
don't want to sit in at 2:00 in the
morning and either somebody robbed the
bank and pulls off and shoot you in the
head when you're in that van me you
gonna write jokes you're drinking coffee
somebody comes in and shoots shot on
evaluations my life
plus the food is horrific if I die cuz
I'm in that place eating shitty food I
would shoot myself like before the guy
came in and pulled the gun I go that
that uh I deserved the night just to be
in here knowing that the food sucks give
me the gun I'll shoot
I wish that's how bad I think I know
that's why I ordered the spaghetti
one time you had to see what this looked
like had a bay leaf still in it oh my
god it was [ __ ] the ugly I'm likely
don't eat it just send it back let's get
on the real fly that we used to go over
there from after the haha we used to go
in there after yes and that place is
just [ __ ] horrific it's horrible
little spot my brother
everybody has a different journey
everybody has a different path
especially this cop again
yeah number one you can't look at what
anybody else is doing I said only the
other day and I'll tell you again
thinking is the enemy of men and
especially in our business but we have
to think so if we go look we have to
think we'll make it quarterly and if you
get the press for three days every 90
days
and then get back in that's how I did my
time yeah every 90 days is
disappointment it takes you two days you
suck it up you look at the want ads you
tell yourself you're gonna go back and
look for a job and you [ __ ] something
good happens you gonna laugh factor
you're gonna standing ovations another
way home you're scratching your head no
I can't quit this so I'm the best thing
about this situation Rick
you ain't no I'm proud of you because
you kept the [ __ ] podcast God gets
going still you're still there you're
still there on your movies and that is
really your passion yeah stand up you
like Richard Pryor listen let's face it
you only going on the road but no but
we'll also do it as hobby get a little
paycheck and do your little podcast and
[ __ ] keep doing your thing you're the
best in the business when it comes to
arguing about films
there's nobody I'm telling you there's
more knowledge than you well plus I know
the passion you have for it the passion
you have for film is stronger than
anything I've ever seen on any body when
I was a kid I had a passion yeah fulfill
I would wait for a film I knew the date
of the release was an corrector from
whether the lunch yeah what the movie
was about I was there front and center
yeah one-fifteen the movie came out I
was there one who's not gonna clock an
attention stone and with a full stomach
full of [ __ ] Chinese food I can name
10 movies right off the top my head
that I was there opening day with no
wine no drama I was getting in first I
was getting on that [ __ ] movie
theater first with a full hi I still
remember dog being in the [ __ ]
halfway house having to dirty you ways
the third when you're going to prison
but I didn't give a [ __ ] because a movie
was coming out that Friday called
Goodfellas and I remember still but I
read the book when I was locked up in
prison and I heard that movie was coming
out that was like sleepers like I was
right there with sleepers came out
because I read the book and Seattle Josh
wolf gave me the book I loved all those
situations silence or land you go see
the movie but what were we talking
Goodfellas 1990 Scorsese just yeah if
I'm nothing up in the halfway house
they're gonna throw me in prison oh my
god my head there Joey
I'm gonna take a little chance on my
life
I'm like a gentleman about 11:30 I went
to the [ __ ] little Chinese place I
used to go to I thought lunch special
I'll never eat the egg roll the egg roll
was for [ __ ] but then many didn't I
Szechuan beef or team rice nice lor I
drop soup some noodles in the soup and
left there I did in those days I was in
the halfway house but I always had a gym
when I was married I had this hidden
little gym maybe the size of this I paid
35 bucks for it it was on the other side
of [ __ ] Pearl Street and in the
middle hunger punching bag and I had a
way it's a stereo and then I had
different compartments all over the
place like tools but it wasn't tools I'm
gonna hide weeding there and sometimes
an eight ball of coke or and I was
pushed under the punching bag I had
hiding places in there so I would roll a
joint a skinny skinny joint and I knew
they were gonna drug test me yeah it
will always really drug test me I would
take a hit off that joint and I would go
to that gym and just go
and I'll blow it out wash my hands and
then from then on I would just drink
water water water but before I leave I'd
hit that bag for an hour my [ __ ]
sweats would be drenched and it hissed a
little before my knees that said that
THC was gone well I would she and I
never got busted for TSA they always got
me for Coke but I always just took one
hit that I stole my marine that Chinese
food running over that taking that one
one hit and gonna see those rags to
riches I did yet I didn't give a [ __ ] if
I went to jail for that I was not going
to see Goodfellas sober that's how
stupid I was this to let you know not
was there's a magic to that though you
know I remember when I saw it I was high
school I was about it was I was probably
a sophomore or a junior and we all went
to see it and we're laughing our asses
off and the [ __ ] straights are
sitting there like what the [ __ ] is
these kids are [ __ ] this is not
funny and we're just screaming the whole
time at how funny this [ __ ] movie is
and that's when I learned it was just
like [ __ ] movies a magic man they
made things make sense I watch movies
now and I'm just like no matter how
shitty my day is if I go home I booked
midnight run on it's over what the best
was the best movie you've let what's the
last yeah the last year about the last
year no no yet there hasn't been much of
anything you know really I mean the
harry dean stanton film was kind of
sweet to see him go out
Logan was really well done and for like
out for like a because it's not like a
comic book movie it's more like a this
weird kind of noir like you could see
Robert Mitchum playing this guy at a
certain point you know [ __ ] what the
hell the Jackie Chan movie was good
because it was like Oceania the
foreigner a lot like a lot of martial
arts yeah he at 63 years old I'm amazed
that the guy can still fight I mean he's
on another level man that dudes a real
deal who knows husband takes care of
himself unbelievable ya know Mike black
it was Mike Black's birthday
and I said my black Jackie Chan is gonna
be at the American Cinematheque the
Egyptian they're gonna show three movies
he was like I can make it through maybe
two I was like I don't give a [ __ ]
just get your ass over there all right
so I got us tickets we went Jackie Chan
was there he spoke the RZA was
interviewing you're like yeah but I'm
watching Police Story Police Story three
in this movie he did called miracles
it's amazing to watch a man move the way
he did because a human being shouldn't
be able to do this [ __ ] I mean he's
hanging the invaders all his own he did
yeah he does all his own stunts he might
not do him as much now but we're talking
about movies that went back to the mid
80s and there's a fight scene the final
fights that end in this business movie
miracles is it's like a remake of a fare
of a Frank Capra movie he's he's he's
fighting in a rope factory on these huge
stilt like-like-like platforms and they
got these rollers cut filled with a rope
that are being pushed and you know there
are moments there where he can fall 20
30 feet and he's holding on the rope and
he's pulling himself up just by body
straight it's just [ __ ] amazing and
what he could do and I watched this
thing and I'm thinking to myself you
know all respect to Bruce Lee and
everything but Bruce Lee just kicked
people's asses he didn't do what Chan
did Chan did these things that were like
superhuman he was on a whole other level
so it was like fighting and it was like
the stunts and I mean I've seen him do
[ __ ] that most other actors would have
died making these films he phenomenal
it's almost like parkour before parkour
yeah yeah and they were actually talking
about that the RZA was talking about how
he inspired a lot of that a lot of that
French [ __ ] and that that Brazilian
parkour and that that moved over to they
made a couple of movies in France called
d13 which really cool [ __ ] but it's all
based on Jackie Chan running jumping
over things you if he could walk through
a gate he never walked right through the
gate he would he would kind of
crisscross his way up a set of walls
over the gate and then just go over
there and kick the [ __ ] out of somebody
it was I was
another level but there was a there was
a respect for the image you know it was
a respect for for being able to to to
create this thing that that as you're
watching it you imagine yourself as
Jackie Chan you know you imagine
yourself doing these fight scenes you
imagine yourself in that world and even
even at 63 the foreigner delivered
delivered man and he's delivering on a
dramatic role that you didn't think he
was capable of not for a guy like you
yeah when you see it if so how happy are
you still I'm thrilled I need I still
want to go on off you found want to see
The Godfather
no I went to see the other one the one
with Cleese would the Chinese kids we
took a little sail long yeah yeah and
they're saying all these poor Asian
slings and we're sitting there with
everything I don't even know what to do
with her lap and he started laughing
yeah oh okay I'll [ __ ] laugh then we
had a great time but you know we went to
see like two or three movies in a row
because they had clearance then there
was no children the phone wasn't ringing
yeah who's I am the phone don't ring it
was a little when we were living over
there by the Y in Indian Hollywood we
were hanging out all the time you blew
my mind by the passion that you have
like some people talk to talk you're a
guy that really walks the walk the shame
with you is we haven't figured out what
agent to get a guy like him to do what
you do best which is argue film
you know you know about cinematographers
yeah you know that when he shot the
movie his wife stabbed him a week before
because in cheated on over the Puerto
Rican chick down during the hurricane
yeah I mean you're the type of guy that
knows all that information he's
passionate
well if you're fast it's fascinating to
and you love terrible movies and you
love sensational movies and just like
everybody else we all there's a bunch of
movies that I watched and I go I love
this movie to some people it's [ __ ]
terrible but maybe I haven't
movie unlikely it was a boomerang boomer
is great
Eddie Murphy Martin [ __ ] Lawrence the
father bang bang bang yeah [ __ ] you
know all those movies I I know there was
a part me one like there was two movies
I don't know by that time I'm lyin to ya
by that time I had seen that I was two
movies I know interesting watch do the
right thing uh-huh
well I watched it I still watch it when
it's on now and I love Spike Lee or what
was another Spike Lee one it was Harlem
Nights okay another movie you lose
forever watch Harlem Nights no I haven't
no autumn nights has moments haha the
Knights had some great moments in ice is
so [ __ ] good Lee if you don't want to
just right in in when you staying with
your wife don't show up here on Sunday
that's it if you don't watch Harlem
Nights at your mom you're gonna dial you
know what they don't want to remake not
a remake they don't part to the coming
to America really yeah okay I've heard
I've heard this you hope they wanted to
America was on somewhere about a month
ago knows you know enough with this
[ __ ] I'm no writer I've no Hemingway
nobody trying to write a clever joke
yeah like I might as well write a joke
about jock itch [ __ ] coming to
America i watch the whole thing so
Larry's it's brilliant when you watch
somebody's movies and you're like this
is 30 [ __ ] years old how is this
dough on it is so [ __ ] relevant there
are times when I go see a movie and I'm
just like [ __ ] they don't there's you
know the biggest problem that I have
right now is that there's nothing in
theaters that really connects I'll go
see a movie don't be like all right that
was a good waste of a couple hours I
wanted to see Thor do it which one saw
some with door you know what it's fun
for a kitty type of thing but it's not a
you know I had I had a good time with it
I loved the Hulk Jeff Goldblum was great
in it but overall I'm just tired of
these [ __ ] Marvel movies they don't
really don't deliver anymore they're
just you know you can only be a kid for
so long I know you're that agent that
hires you just say gentle Cheney on
auditions even though you're Jewish but
you have a something lasting I mean what
the [ __ ] Jamaica and they like listen
I'm [ __ ] Jewish bro much with the
Spanish
all these guys want to say they wanna
yeah it's the same thing with the marble
thing and like listen it's it's a I have
a stand against them yeah like I don't
think adults should be gonna see that
[ __ ] just but that's me cuz I'm an
[ __ ] listen bro
and the more people pay for these ending
the more money than me well that's a
whole they get lazy they put it together
every day
no they're just they're just making [ __ ]
because they know people are gonna go
see it when you see a great film like I
mean I can't remember the problem I
can't remember when I saw a great film
in a theatre I can't remember when I saw
a movie that really blew me away
and I was just like god damn that was
good I can't wait to fly yeah
on Thursdays because especially if I'm
going like Delta or a JetBlue or
something because I might see a [ __ ]
movie that might blow me away like I
still never be able to long as yard and
having no coke and being in New Mexico
and being [ __ ] bored but I got a big
bag of weed maybe I get some room
service I don't know where to go
yeah my girlfriend's up here I got no
girlfriend down there you know he's
watching TV like no pay-per-view movies
why must I still love this no Special K
I still remember scrolling and seeing a
picture of Denzel with a gun in his hand
one explosion behind me knowing this guy
was good as the [ __ ] saxophone play
oh yeah and he was great in this movie
and he was great in the movie with the
slaves when he got whipped and he was
tremendous and training there but he
wants to help I'll never forget ordering
like room service like animal would give
you the other thing when you book a
movie called what's a community Rodya so
I would take the bird and go at someone
when they feed me on the truck yeah but
I don't really want to leave I'm gonna
watch the Denzel movie and revenue
as political been on my never know this
move oh [ __ ] yeah
room service do me a favor let me get a
cheeseburger in those days they had the
kids mac and cheese oh the kids mac and
cheese was bigger than all six orders of
others no there was one order like that
it was just shells with cheese all over
them underneath nearly cooked cheese
Italian sauce Jesus Christ I don't never
gets it and also there's this guy and
you see Christopher Walken I got
something to work with
how bad could it be and just sitting
there at the end with tears running down
the face with a napkin with my leg
twitching you know I'm saying like that
says it's the levels it's like he takes
you on a [ __ ] right and what was the
that's the last time I was [ __ ] moved
oh I fell off my chair and quadroon
services go listen well they're gonna
charge me every watch just right now all
it's gonna cost an extra 995 were saying
you I already wants to [ __ ] thing is
there any way for free no it's on the
caution than any [ __ ] I got per diem
and I just click that out yeah that was
that that's what like when I watched
angel heart to be halftime I want though
she don't wanna talk and you're not on a
Sunday me by myself
in those days I used to go get his
chicken cutlets and there was his place
roses and mold on crossing the Fox Tina
and they used to have this late 87 way
before boredom Morgan or anybody else
living in Vegas these [ __ ] and
balls were making this chicken and
they're like two different chickens on
the rack and you would see the little
hippie dude rubbing them with lemon and
I would buy the whole [ __ ] half a
rack and eat it smoked a joint knowing
that I move with you on the Lord's Day
jacked on one Sunday I walked in there
and it was angel hall and I saw the
commercial I knew was with De Niro yeah
what could this possibly be about yeah
and also I'm sitting there full and Bob
boom angel on Rihanna so he has I'm
lying to you guys I want the same talk
my ex-wife we sat in the movie theater
we wants angel heart and
the end of it I told that looked like no
that was the best thing I ever saw oh
yeah
but I have no idea what just happened
till I saw mood like it was that was the
thing it's like you didn't know you
didn't know who it was like what was
Mickey working that moves like so what
it says he in his own green what's an
endless oh yeah let's sit and watch it
again yeah we got nowhere to go you guys
don't win the war my mother's cooking
[ __ ] call her up tell them we'll be
late and say let's watch Angel Heart
again that's the type of [ __ ] that way
yeah I like to watch some though in the
3/4 in I know what you like and I could
call your dog what are you doing right
now well I'm cutting through put that
knife down
get your ass through video store and get
this yeah the [ __ ] will be tonight
and you'll tell me I saw it oh my god
I was thinking about getting it BAM yeah
I love that that is my favorite [ __ ]
feeling that's the thing when you find
something that it's always been there
it's like finding gold in the [ __ ]
dump it's like you didn't know who was
there the first time that I saw thief I
was like are you [ __ ] kidding me and
this is at a time when when remember
Tower Records like when I was a kid
anywhere between 12 and maybe 18 I would
spend all goddamn day in Tower Records
and they had a special Tuesdays and
Thursdays you can get a movie for like a
dollar or something like that so I would
get there right when they opened because
I wanted the pick I wanted my for movies
that were gonna last me those two days I
could take them back on Thursday and get
two more movies that were gonna last me
two days you know and I was just gonna
watch [ __ ] movies and I remember
seeing so many goddamn things foreign
films underground films exploit oh yeah
probably bout 2000 probably if I if I go
[ __ ] got 2,000 films in your
house tweet me all right it's just look
at all the next two days but that's it
do you really a you solid tool I used a
Lee and I'm gonna metal I'm really mad
at myself even you know what the great
thing about DVD is you can go back to
the exact moment and play you know how
many times I've seen good
but how many times I've just watched
dinero sitting at the end of that
[ __ ] bar getting ready to take the
ticket take a toke off that cigarette as
he's thinking about killing Morrie and
sunshine of your love is playing over
the [ __ ] soundtrack the probably the
single greatest [ __ ] thing I've ever
seen in a movie because you sit there
and you're like I don't give a [ __ ] what
anybody tells me about how bad smoking
is for you or how how ugly it is it's
[ __ ] cool as [ __ ] in that movie you
watch Bogart and The Maltese Falcon De
Niro in Midnight Run I wanted to smoke
because of these guys I think of a [ __ ]
bring the [ __ ] cancer I didn't give a
[ __ ] because these guys were cool as
[ __ ] then we'll exaggerated there I know
before I moved here I know what if I
haven't got a movie and I had smoke
because I didn't smoke yeah I don't can
you imagine I got a movie in the ass
misspoke and my character has just
smoked I'm gonna try a cigarette just in
case that's how they got you up yeah
that's how they got me the first time I
all dizzy and [ __ ] in like the same bed
I can't wait to get on stage you want
your little tweaked up to take the
nerves away yeah let me give some
shoutouts I want to ask you something
yeah close my glasses them holy [ __ ]
Jesus Christ my brother the Puerto
Ricans saving the Puerto Rican for real
a lot of people talk a lot of [ __ ] they
don't listen this guy took his own money
he got fired and he actually went to
Puerto Rico so his shout-out goes to my
brother Rene and car seoane my other
brother made Maggiore Majewski Lorne
Rosen car Joey rook 'ln Kevin down-low
Bobby Sheeran Bob love Lingus James
Thomas and angel Alvarado bring it on
home [ __ ] I will see you [ __ ]
this weekend at the New York Comedy
Festival
Rene in Carson will be there Saturday
night for the Late Show besides that it
looks like Tuesday at the Comedy Store
in the original room about 9:15 and
after that I got the improv in Irvine
November 22nd that's it the [ __ ]
years coming to an end you know what are
you thinking this new thing they're
doing would they
and Pacino and the home crew you know
what I would have no faith if it wasn't
Martin Scorsese directing this thing it
stir it Scorsese and Scorsese doesn't
[ __ ] around you know let's be honest I
still got it
I [ __ ] still think he's got it I
don't think he's made a bad movie he's
made movies that aren't as good as as
other films that he's made but the wolf
of Wall Street is a [ __ ] batshit
crazy I don't know I've never used like
that I don't know what what coke is like
but it looked to me like absolutely
refrigerant you got a wild side
yeah my 10th anniversary I know you
don't you you haven't used head [ __ ]
yeah no no using if it you know what
it's a beautiful thing it's a beautiful
thing you know it it's it's what our
pride alone sir
you were bad man oh [ __ ] you told me how
bad you were you you know you everybody
do yes at me I had an idea I just didn't
know for sure and [ __ ] but you know what
you get to a certain point in your life
where you realize you got to change you
got to make it when I saw you know like
when I saw flight did you ever see that
oh she's beautiful
yeah you know she's just a little woman
yeah she ain't even [ __ ] around no
more like last night at our house at
6:30 it was a [ __ ] Awards yeah
it was a [ __ ] war zone in my house at
6:30 my wife made pot roast what did
that mean let them look at my cuz if you
don't want to eat pot roast right there
on the [ __ ] floor yet everything was
kumbaya on the way home there was no
drama but she gets in the car how was
your day
where's my kiss in Spanish she gives me
a kiss she climbs on the seat last week
she stepped on bubblegum and I got on my
seat do I get pissed
[ __ ] not at all she jumps in the car
she tells me about a [ __ ] day she
beats us to death then she's like where
are we going like what a [ __ ] we go oh
only on but whether you want to go with
a little mac and cheese restaurant which
is [ __ ] Boston Market and then the
Italian restaurant is Maria's yeah and
then sandwiches Jersey Mike's she likes
the salami sandwich with [ __ ] cheese
plain you ever knew trusted aromas yet
no no she's not that type of scent
occasion even think of nothing in my way
but all sounds good
apparently I have the same we're gonna
eat pot roast and she's like I know what
she was doing no this rush like I just
don't want it but you don't even know
what this like I'm hearing this back
before you decided to get their
merciless what are you doing for destroy
you don't like it my mom and thank you
so much
but why don't you listen I could just
try the pot roast but daddy I don't want
it listen listen I'm trying to [ __ ]
save you here alright this is before the
Bruce Lee clip oh yeah this is way
before I put the Bruce Lee clip there
was war at the house so I just played my
hand i sat down that's not to sit down
and she's bitching my wife cut the meat
for her with the carrots the whole
[ __ ] thing she's talking some [ __ ]
over there some nonsense and I'm waiting
for this reject my wife's is down and
she says let's say prayers mercy say the
prayers
I'm not saying prayers either I just
[ __ ] proceeded to study the pot roast
without it and watch what this would go
and I loved it every every 90 day she
pushes the envelope deep but it gets so
deep that it bothers me because she
reminded me of me yeah that's the same
emotional damage kinda I was walking up
death no she gets pissed well this went
on for about 30 seconds I'm not saying
prayers mercy to say the prayers go to
bed I'm like all in bed I'm like oh
think of the Saudi but had a [ __ ]
minute
because I know my no my wife my wife
don't take no [ __ ] from no I'll take a
little bit of [ __ ] one my one here and
then but now it's do the time I don't
want him nothing you wanna argue take it
outside
I don't want no arguments well [ __ ]
City that's the messenger to the table
and God don't like arguments at the
[ __ ] table so I need to say that they
kept going back
mercy say the prayers I'm not saying
prayers I don't want this I want peanut
butter mercy please just try the [ __ ]
me finally my wife because they called a
bat
she grabbed the push tried all calling
her bad she was in there like the exes
think well I'm not gonna bad I don't
want Bob rouse I just kept eating the
pot roast I hate the potatoes made the
[ __ ] spinach salad I took my heart
place for medication i sat there for
about ten minutes he was still going
nice and this she was jumping up and
down and kicking the floor like Oh bump
oh my my colleague did it I finally went
in there on my listen dog timer you
gotta [ __ ] knock it off I could just
taste the [ __ ] meat that's it just
taste it why are we going through all
this I don't want to eat it I don't like
it just [ __ ] try there's a carrot you
always eat carrots try to [ __ ] carrot
we started jumping up and down and then
she pulled the daughter Carla she loved
how to pull the string and she bought
with her hands up and came to me like a
fancy I see it got hit them by the
Columbia so Kate really pop I go no no
you go eat the [ __ ] meat if she said
I don't wanna offend okay I tried to
bail you out don't don't don't let it
[ __ ] bail yeah
and I closed the door I went out there
and I can see my wife's face getting red
and red I said you know what I gotta
take a ride to seven elegant rolling
papers I have two boxes of rolling
papers and this is a zombie apocalypse I
got I got rolling papers hidden baggies
and waterproof [ __ ] boxes just in
case of a zombie apocalypse me and we
getting paid 70/30 anyway
bro on her left there was [ __ ] going on
there like it was the Exorcist yeah I
went I went there [ __ ] whatever I
bought some nicotine gum to go ride the
long way around the neighborhood and
when I got back she was tilted to the
table rosy cheeks eating the pot roast
and the carrot I knew something went
down when I walked like I seen my wipers
I'm selling know what happens because I
have a read of the [ __ ] riot act and
I was like I don't want to know she goes
you have no idea and but never even put
my daughter walked up and Misha
apologize that I'm sorry I know it broke
happens but you got a taste for [ __ ]
meat you can't just say it I don't wanna
be waited all this [ __ ] when you were a
baby yeah when she was a baby if she
would eat the skin off salmon listen
only savages greasy [ __ ] skin off
penetration of the salmon
she'll eat that disgusting duration look
even give me more disgust kids are the
[ __ ] hardest thing to deal with man
ground mafia 43 you feel me
you're a good writer you got a little
resume you got some tape and then over
till the fat lady sings it ain't over
revamped gave a little notebook write
your goals down just because you know
destroyed this lemon you're not a
comedian
no I know and it does not mean you have
any heart you still got you billion now
you gotta go I know now you gotta shoot
a [ __ ] now you got no choice you
can't go to the home empty-handed if you
go home now it's like I smacked you ten
times in the stomach I don't like your
bags on what so now you're 43
talking about you got 20 years to retire
you know Junior soprano how old was he
when he got The Sopranos you wanna check
IMDB you got a lot of life left
well that's the thing Lisa I yeah let it
listen to these stories man it's not to
be afraid of
he's my brother Rick Ramos I never
thought down of him or anything yeah but
I always know - you drew the safety that
out your full commitment was not you're
not gonna book a role
you're not gonna figure out how to book
a role until you a little hungry
The Times written in that little two
hundred thousand he got hit the next
and while Ghana Nicholls believes it
the money is long gone stop it's [ __ ]
commerce that I between the bunnies you
got money hidden everywhere save or you
still had Nazi bonds you got something
more money [ __ ] both these this guy
worked as a schoolteacher ten hours a
day he was making twenty two hundred
thousand a year they quit when they got
five cuz he yelled some little [ __ ]
Mexican kid he's like no the kids are
[ __ ] [ __ ] what are you what am I
supposed to do you know try maybe a
teach is a tough job [ __ ] that I put up
with you had the comedy from it but
listen brother [ __ ] all that [ __ ] no
it's the month I didn't think when you
came on this podcast and like I didn't
even think we're gonna talk about half
the [ __ ] we talked about but I one thing
that I always talk about in this podcast
and wheeze my witnesses the morning you
ain't done - you ain't yeah
I'm 54 guys you ain't over this
[ __ ] game is never over
I thought I was done at 40 I really
really thought I was not at 40 bro I
really thought I was done to be 40 54 I
wake up every morning so happy I go I
can't believe it
I can't even know who this guy is but it
doesn't matter I'm still here and I
still work this is hard right yes it's a
different hardness oh I know you do one
thing you cannot have you're already if
you don't do it for [ __ ] me you don't
do a figure of this door from Maryland
who's dead and she never had the chance
well always told me if she ever got back
to the hospital she was gonna revamped
myself like Madonna yeah I mean it's
tough to believe she was no Madonna he's
up Sam let me tell you something you
bothered me a little bit with what you
said about how you shouldn't have acted
that way at her funeral yeah you and I
both know that woman yeah she would have
loved all the boy went down so what a
love how [ __ ] nuts and the violence
she was I could hear her screaming
during that whole thing on the only
people I insulted that night yeah I had
Sultan maybe eight people
there's only one person that I've looked
at and I can take myself because I
really really love the way I was Andrew
Dice klutz
Andrew kept ask me what happened why are
you so red are you okay
and I wouldn't even reply little I'm
like if I go back in that mine I think I
went back in there and they were gone
yeah they were gone so what happened was
to get thinking this story I'm trying to
stay clean I get talked into going to
this [ __ ] figure The Comedy Store and
I go and then I have a drink and I go in
there and somebody went up first and
then go Joey you got to go up second and
talk please don't put me up that was a
big mistake it was just a mistake and I
knew it Lee I know me it was a mistake
me going down it because I will I love
somebody when I go to a wake it's all
the people I died no I'm not crying for
you I'm crying for Ralphie I'm crying
for Anthony miles down I'm crying for
Dominick special
I'm dying for Freddie some drive for all
they have already that meant yeah all
those emotions I had my mother my father
all those people you know talk I'm
starting to miss Ralphie Saturday
sometimes I look out my phone just
because Ralphie used to call me on the
road on Saturday mornings I'd wake up
for breakfast thinking that was it
because I'm on the East Coast it's 8:00
in the morning
it's 5:00 Lee's not gonna call me one
problem my wife ain't gonna call me and
I'd be sitting there I just go to the
hotel like I always get up early on
silent
I go to bed late I get up early and then
I [ __ ] eat something at the hotel
like oatmeal I get two eggs sunny-side
up so who eat toast and three pieces of
bacon and then I smoke a joint I go back
upstairs and hopefully it's like a long
on a marathon this two episodes alone
before [ __ ] rush hour then I'm saying
on TNT and I watch both of those things
and then I just pass out but I'll if I
fall asleep at 10:00 it's 7:00 I can't
call my wife but the only person who
would call me every Saturday he won't
look at my schedule see if it was on the
road he would always call me on
Saturdays at 8:15 was Ralphie
where I was I could be that I'd see that
phone [ __ ] delivery yeah well [ __ ]
this quality [ __ ] Ralphie what's up
dog not well being his hotel the food
sucks
you know you know the whole thing so now
it takes time and Maryland I don't miss
as much as I used to when she first
passed but I still think about I took
lead to a cochinita and I showed Lee
that's her Marilyn used to live out of
respect yeah well when he was sitting
like this and they go run up it doesn't
even look the same
yeah I don't want to go back like what
up there about two years ago whatever I
go to the cochinita on the way back I
make the u-turn
I'll coach you eat those one of the
finest Cuban restaurants in the area
it's become it took them point but took
them 19 years of eating there and they
pushed me over the hump and I finally
took lead two weeks ago we had to go do
be real podcast and we said [ __ ] it
let's take it over
I never took me there and I got the
[ __ ] bike I'll leave the pork chunks
with the [ __ ] white rice and the
black beans
and tell them what else I got junk away
Cuban fried rice oh my god the plantains
oh I am taking rice bananas okay so they
got the best fried rice in California
they have had yeah like it's really
[ __ ] good like East Coast a lot of
sprouts a lot of eggs yeah green onions
they got like pork with us thing on
their little shrine like pork ham oh
they have everything in there but you
gotta eat it there yeah don't take it
the wrong way no [ __ ] no but it stunk up
the car for phone for [ __ ] days every
time I got anything other [ __ ] hungry
I thought I'd finally I activate through
all the shows and what's going on there
everything good you got any questions oh
that right there and then make a right
right there lock the door and make sure
the cameras none of these been out
disgusting
perverts in this world no but I got damn
I think about her I think about her it's
weird cuz sometimes I don't think about
her at all and then boom she just pops
into my head look he pops into my
it's it's it's just I wish he was around
to see my daughter and if she really
fueled my love for cats yeah we would
talk a lot about cats I would call her
and she knew everything about cats and
she bust my balls I'll never forget the
time I called her I told her I made a
mistake with the cat I thought it was a
female she was yes that's a [ __ ] I
asked all I was called the cat princess
people [ __ ] fat conflicts yeah I was
a male if you found that it's funny man
when you do comedy with people you build
this weird bond you know sometimes you
guys are looking at Twitter a son and
you see a tour together you see four
comics and you said yourself wow I
didn't know Joey and we we're friends
well one of that tour together were big
four big names
we're probably really not friends we
just had to take publicity pictures and
we'll make believe we're having a great
time it's like when you see George
Clooney and Brad Pitt giggling like I
had one of those events
yeah they talk on the phone every day no
they see each other all Zahn they're
best friends cuz there's cameras around
but the funny thing happens that those
guys are making money so they have to
get along with each other and give you
the personas can be a great time than
what it they you don't see these people
and there's a certain comic so like Josh
wolf Josh wolf and I would call
headliners when Seau together back in
1995 again it's 2017
this is 1995 and for maybe three years
and when I did all those local gigs yeah
yeah together you and I were brothers in
the comedy school yeah and Marilyn was
one of our sisters there and I still
remember the night you got passed oh god
I still learn like they passed you how
emotional you are you I called my mom
sure from the pay phone remember I
called my mom a phone I was proud of
that moment that I was graduating from
college okay it meant so much to me to
listen for everything that's happened in
20 [ __ ] years you got two major
accomplishments that can happen to a lot
of people first one you became a regular
at the store
you got passed by Mitzi sure yeah you're
not one of these okey-doke [ __ ]
in number two you also shadow Latino
special and they still play on Showtime
yeah and we don't get a dime corner yeah
so comedy slim you have so much to work
for it don't give up at this point I'm
not but do me a favor
yeah it's 2017 you've been here so long
every day you wake up your mother's
getting older your father's getting
older your nephews getting all the
ancestors getting older I know you want
to be down there make the death count if
you have a [ __ ] get up every morning
and be away from your mother
don't be a favor for one year take the
year off I'll help you as much as I can
I will take down the road as much as I
can but if you haul me up like a man
when they no Joey I'm gonna give this
one more you in if it does if I don't
get them if I don't get [ __ ] a I will
move back to [ __ ] whatever and become
a big celebrity down there play the
organ at the baseball game and throw out
the first ball yeah let's go for broke
all right let's go for broke
you know I'm trying to do this Netflix
thing I'll take you in as many dates as
I can't get him saying I got a small
hand around but at least just to give
you some confidence and get you in front
of good audiences from here on in I want
you to prepare but the most important
thing the fear factor has to you you
know we had Wesley Walker in here yes
wheeler Walker again I'm very sorry to
do this to you edit Lee leather skin it
well it's candid Oakland 1977 do you
need to go anything a equal okay
it's your phone we can't miss my love no
you know I want you to think about this
because I was telling Wesley we all have
rough days but you'll have days that you
know not all of us yeah could be [ __ ]
brad pitt bro
God didn't throw us that card and
whatever it just
so those days you wake up and you have
doubts about what you do what are you
trying to do you tell your father I want
to be a [ __ ] piano playing he's like
you're in no danger put your fat little
[ __ ] fingers you had a hard time
wiping Asti it was 16 how you gonna be
up you know nobody believes in what you
don't you know it's kind of weird and
put it he'll we saw this last night
speed it up a little bit to like right
there or something
you know I saw this and for years
because of prior and the influences I
had yeah and being at the store and
being put at the position I was put up
at the lineup
I would always load a little bit late I
would always uh you know you learn to be
aggressive yeah but then I saw this and
there's a list it's an interesting as
can get this is the Oakland Coliseum
it's 1977 they didn't sell it out by
themselves and I think if somebody wants
to look it up I think that they were
part of a tour like them and Mott the
Hoople or something like it was a little
Saturday afternoon things yeah looks
like a festival like a festival right
there its Oakland it's not Texas it's
not the south and I didn't like this put
this a little and look at these guys and
look at how they're acting okay there's
no dancing there's no matching outfits
you took these guys who really care what
they look like when they went up on
stage look at the nice guy singer with a
hat on with a t-shirt or maybe
Andy Warhol on it not speeding it up a
little bit my brother may be right there
[Music]
they didn't get the memo that they
weren't people want to look at these
people
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
little [ __ ] with a confederate flag
heaven Oakland Jack all right we got the
Presidents on top it's 1977 look it all
the way up it's filled to the brim
he's a white kid this is a [ __ ] this
isn't the country look at these guys on
stage do you think they kept that day
job
[Music]
flippin they don't give a [ __ ] Rick they
didn't even hit the medal they thought
they were doing a bar on it and bubbles
out and then we're gonna roast a pig
nobody told them they were know for
metalmouth up if you don't have this
attitude this business huh
some [ __ ] and I know you could
put this together because I know for a
fact for a fact you're way better than
half the people that do a movie [ __ ] you
just have to dig deep and figure out how
you can make a living do what the [ __ ]
you do and I think I'm gonna hook you up
with Mauricio Alvarado and do his little
prep the ship for 90 days and [ __ ]
areas little buttons and [ __ ] I think
you're more resealed big good fit
because you're a funny guy and we got
two of the best credits you could have I
don't want you to feel defeated there's
no reason why you should be doing that
extra work didn't we go that little gay
guy for a while that was datin [ __ ]
was that you or me or was that Rivero
and me which one that we went to what's
a guy from Apocalypse Now Laurence
Fishburne yeah I'm always we went to his
boyfriend school was the mean you'll not
read three things you read we go okay it
was me and Rodrigo at least tonight a
little Mexican do it after that he's
like oh no it's the same
no cuz Ellen because Rodrigo and I sadly
do look to say no no that we all die no
we're all really into acting and Rodrigo
will really talk about films and yeah
you know I mean we would talk about the
scenes that really meant the most to us
and those moments where you were like
[ __ ] that was that was real that was
honest that was like you know but you
want another level it's it's a strange
love to have when you have the I have
the love of cinema you have when I was
23 elected when I was robbing apartments
well I had day time to watch three or
four movies in a row you know and now
you know as you get older you want to
watch everything I try to watch
everything on a plane yeah you know as
much as I can know that I watched Planet
of the Apes I got totally the most
racist thing I've ever seen in my life
cow I don't ever want to watch that
again that was me that was written by
racist people like what could we do to
stop them mmm
let's write a movie and put eggs in
there but the fur like I said breathe
the plan leaves the originals beneath
the Planet X is mine
I know I was a little kid living in New
York City and when I went to see that
[ __ ] they took the skins off you know
but I say mmmm and there was all veins
issue
I loved it you know I tell you sometimes
it's when the movie hits you when the
movie I don't know I mean when I saw
easy money in a theater and I was
[ __ ] 10 1983 summer of 83 deal which
was maybe six nine years old it was the
biggest home tyke America couldn't wait
for Rodney to [ __ ] through something
and the word was up dog Rodney
Dangerfield got his own [ __ ]
movie yeah like no more Caddyshack I'm
not gonna be a supporting kid and I
didn't know how you live e and tell you
I do Joe Pesci was I had no [ __ ] idea
look with Joe Pesci was the first time I
went to see easy money but I remember
that was the first time and I'm naive or
whatever that was the first time I've
been told a lot of movies that I brought
beer in there and I don't drink but the
whole movie theater was banging our
beers because you can't hearing the
bottles in before they roll down they'll
I tell you there were moments somebody
in the back how many know yours hmm
I packed stood him up I'm a gentleman
you stand them up until you leave and
then you kick them over all at once but
they're in a movie you don't [ __ ]
kick them over so during this movie
every like eight minutes you hear the
guy put the bottle down and it would
just grow and that's the movie theater
with Halle black them because yeah that
was when when movie theaters were at a
slatted slang word they'd like this zone
oh because I think Holly works yeah
looking to Comedy Works it's always like
a little slowly [ __ ] when you go down
the county slip that the comedy works
that's - that's what people like about
that Club yeah then you feel like you're
born gladiator yeah see whatever the
[ __ ] he says because the people are
sitting right around you yeah like a
little like a little hand for theater
they're right there see if I mean when
you're at the economy works I'm here
my damn bro for you right there you're
right there you're right there right on
bill I said bang that's why God stays
the first time you know a [ __ ]
terminate is when you see something like
that I mean it's just like god damn you
know the first time that I can I came
out here I guess it was 99 98
I was selling radio airtime in Phoenix
at a black soul station that nobody was
buying this [ __ ]
it had no [ __ ] signal and a buddy of
mine got his tickets out here and he was
like you want to go see la I was like
yeah I want to move there and I came out
here on a Tuesday and Paul Mooney was
hosting the original room and you know I
was a huge paw MODY fan and I want I
went in there and I watched this [ __ ] I
was just like I want this I want this so
bad and I would see I saw Brian Holtzman
I saw some of the craziest [ __ ] I ever
imagine Ryan hosted still goes up there
and they still put him up on Saturday
nights at about 1:30 then he goes up
there and destroys that scalpel room and
you know I love a guy yeah that when he
will not stage you were petrified yeah
you like what is this guy gonna make it
if that's how scary he is on stage oh
yeah you like going to comedy next time
on a Saturday night you guys want to go
to Hollywood late a little late 11
o'clock
there'll be 60 people in the audience go
watch the true funniest guy in LA if
he's on fire and if he's clean
cuz he's clean he always clean really
yeah he's been clean for a long time
okay
former airport mechanic playing mechanic
worked at the airlines came out here it
would destroy the original room I mean
we'd sit there in the back screaming
screaming I'll never forget one that it
was packed and he's like I went to see a
new Charlie's Angels
well you they're [ __ ] dying because
that's what you do you go in there who's
on stage Brian Holtzman by you have a
pain you go in the back just ready to
die and he's in there [ __ ] tell me
what this in will be Charlie's Angels
yeah sure I dare you I dare will he used
to do sock karate move I'll break your
[ __ ] neck
I'll take their little [ __ ] neck
gonna [ __ ] break it on the floor and
he's going all in the back everyone said
I'll throw you in the trunk of my car
drive around bumpy roads we would sit
back there me Rogan Mooney you Maryland
we would sit back that at those Holtzman
nights and just spit would be coming out
yeah I don't forget the night they put
the fart dig up there he was up there
was very fab Reid I would go up that
night and put a fart machine under your
seat Lea
so you'd be sitting there all night with
your wife and girlfriend and every time
a comic would do a points line you will
hear before and that's a couple minutes
of comic we go I don't know who the [ __ ]
is fine whoever it is you're another
part and then the comic would finally go
you know what somebody's [ __ ] with me
that's okay I have a good night ladies
and junk and this went on one night for
about three or four comics and there was
a fallout whose thanks Brian also and
he's the shitty mood you know he got
there he's pissed he's drinking when I
was drinking
oh god his comedy was it was something
that by the third minute you won't
[ __ ] die yeah he will go up there
yelling screaming just the most insane
[ __ ] just the most insane crazy all the
one about his mother
they had a kid they used to suck his
dick what you just taking it to a
baseball game and I'm good my son's my
son my my gay son my son I have a gay
son that stood out was it that was the
one that used to make people get up you
know we're not here I already would say
was like is the best ballplayer
most home runs most batted in and I take
him out to the i5 a little moussaka
I let him suck on a truck driver [ __ ]
that's a resort
Dixie thanks money I love my gay son
people would get up and run out of there
or people would take them on but we
thought they were seeing the devil where
he was on his game yeah scary and then
Damon Wayans walked in one night saw put
her mother's show yeah as a recurring
character he doesn't want to do what but
he don't want to quit his job either he
didn't like was Johnny well he get he
moved to then he moved through well he
got clean and sober he moved to Hermosa
Beach and became a dog catcher that's
the funniest [ __ ] style I'd be a dog
catcher so I would be the name of rogue
in that Hermosa Beach before I got
banned from down there got me magic club
I'm banned for life before I got banned
in them and then one night and wholesome
runs that I do a guessing it yeah why do
you have a uniform on you didn't know
thinking about tickets hand I'm the dog
catcher
Freddy with parking enforcement a
parking enforcement and the dog catcher
oh my god but the single funniest guy
you'd ever seen he still comes up to the
Comedy Store the [ __ ] new spots on
salaries have written John I'm gonna
taste one it's been a pleasure to have
you on the show and to see I'm so glad
there were no you're healthy and to know
that you still have a lot of damage that
needs to be done you never answer me
what you thought about the De Niro movie
which one the Irishman yeah what do you
think it's gonna be like what have you
heard what have you read I'm thinking
that this guy stick you know there was a
moment in um was like this movie done
already they were talking about it they
wanted to get it done I think there are
a couple of directors involved in it
they did him the Irishman oh no no no
that's a different film that was uh that
was about it was about a hitman who this
is a hitman to but this was uh this is
based on arm this is based on a book
called you paint houses right and in the
storyline what what happened was when
they wanted to
somebody they wanted to get rid of
somebody they would call a number and
they say I hear you paint houses which
means that they're talking to a guy who
kill shoot people in the head and paints
the wall with blood you know and that's
his name Frank Frank the Irishman
something but that's that was a
different film I have that film in my
collection that was I can't remember the
actor but I don't Paul Sorvino was in it
and a couple of other children would or
was it as a garbage surfer was in it
okay Robert Davi was in Abu Dhabi was in
Laos and that's the one him I think I
read for that one got dick they may like
formal wisdom for my movies idea I would
like all four for like 2009 right now
yeah something like that there was like
mm yeah somewhere I got here going into
Christmas I was doing a mafia movie in
Spokane Washington where I had a warrant
yeah I was like how am i doing they go
five weeks there when he gave me a
number
it was Val Kilmer this one that one
wasn't a bad lineup I walked on that
killed him in the audition it was
somewhere in the valley and they said
would you were willing to go to a tailor
and get fitted for suits I said yeah
the row was made I never heard from you
people again never got the job and after
that it was like three or four-month
things I went in four in a row that was
one of them one of those [ __ ] what's
that show on TNT it's on ABC about the
author that writes books and he's got a
chick friend Castle castle Castle got a
mobster over there once it's the only
times I've been in four Castle probably
eight [ __ ] time it's over now is it
yeah I'll never get countless
[ __ ] you they like you yeah but
then they were [ __ ] book me now they
look good they like me but they don't
look minim I would watch the episode in
the beer soprano on day one Sopranos and
that that was it I couldn't get dick a
while they're Sopranos as a even if you
played a mailman on the surah Anam I'm
not crying I'm happy as [ __ ] no and I'm
happy that I got to see you don't know I
love I love being here I love kitchen
I'm listening to your podcast watch this
with the Rick Ramos we're talking about
Harvey Weinstein this week we're talking
about the scandals we're talking about
all the way back to the earlier of the
silent era Roscoe Fatty Arbuckle
Virginia
we're talking about Natalie Wood well
you know Jayne Mansfield passing away I
mean people are talking about this
Harvey Weinstein like it's the worst
thing an imagined a by living this
exactly Marilyn Monroe got passed and
God rest his soul that beautiful woman
they had a bag of the president a
gangster uh uh you know it was English
always been that way it's always been
that you know it's so funny that now
they edged light on this [ __ ] fake
[ __ ] thing that would be this is what
we were talking about it was like these
people are vilifying Harvey Weinstein
who was a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] no doubt
but these are the same people that were
standing in line the kids Roman
Polanski's s and he asked raped the
thirteen-year-old girl he drugged her
anally raped her fagioli raped her
orally raped her and they're saying oh
we should forgive him and let him come
back into the country [ __ ] that this
this goddamn industry is evil on that
level and I'm just kind of disgusted
with the whole now this this high and
mighty [ __ ]
this shit's been going on for [ __ ]
years yeah I want to know you know what
I almost put on whenever I was thinking
about how would the agents that sent you
to a hotel room yeah to me would agree
to meet with Steven Seagal or these you
know what's that my love yeah cuz they
knew could get them in there yeah and
then you know well didn't they say Bill
Cosby you had like like enemies we have
people that would would take care of it
you know what that's the thing when
you're making money for them yeah they
will cover up everything they will go
out of their way you know and part of me
is like well these women should have
said something and the fact that they
took the money meant that you know it
continued the victimization but you know
what you're a woman in Hollywood
sometimes you're sitting there telling
yourself they're not gonna do anything
anyway I might as well get a little
something out of it old McGowan got like
a million dollars out of it you know but
I'm glad they're bringing the I'm glad
they're bringing him down now [ __ ] him
but in no way is this a unique thing not
having his face he's not you
this [ __ ] has been going on for years
what's funny because I went to eat
Tuesday night I did a great Fitzsimmons
radio show and after what I met my agent
and he went to this restaurant over
sitting there and there were three other
like big-time aides it's supposedly they
don't me I don't say no but I'd say my
[ __ ] dinner but the guy they were
talking they go first of all he's not
getting fired filleted that 30 years ago
he got fired for this [ __ ] that's been
going on the last three years on this
set oh yeah you know what people don't
realize is if you if you watch the movie
by Liberace in one day but I read a book
about him years ago and something I
watched I don't know maybe 15 years ago
before the movie was over me that that
towards the end he got a really creepy
yeah because they become queens and now
they get a really aggressive right it's
like boomerang yeah when the chicken Oh
wonderful kid without the kid he has
home Eddie Murphy have you seen that Lee
I think you should be part of that then
we should move parts of hello boomerang
Eartha Kitt and Eddie Murphy anyou make
it darker yeah dark ahead dad but he did
it and that's what was great about it
yeah yeah because he knew he didn't
complain and Sewer you know what was
great about that is that Murphy Murphy
played weak and Murphy remember when
Murphy hit Murphy was the coolest
[ __ ] to ever do it again
you know sterling were walking into the
movie theater on a cold night huh how
the Sun they like to see [ __ ] Beverly
Hills no trading Oh 48 hours on all of
them Trey like that dad Trading Places I
saw in a movie theater in Aspen Colorado
yeah in 19 this summer of 83
see if it says boomerang Eddie Murphy
what's the scene with everything I hit
hit seduction at the kids deduction II a
are th some right there right yeah
that's it
do you remember
he just he daddy goes right there
boomerang move up but it starts in the
living room
oh that's it yeah boomerang right that
starts out the first one up on top it
starts in the living room with the Black
Butler answers laughing is that laughing
his ass off because he knows even when
he turns away you can hear very
attractive woman standing out of bed and
heels
she's about 65 oh god yeah yeah and with
a baby the suit from the 50s is one of
the original cat women room he's got the
hula stockings on from head to toe with
no space think automatically they make a
woman's feet snow funny I like toes I'm
not your ally [ __ ] oh I don't want a
burglar hat on right would you like to
dim it make a little more romantic
[Music]
up here town she's old yeah didn't see
that that was I remember that you know
whether the cool thing there's a moment
remember when Robin Givens comes over
she [ __ ] him and then she leaves and
she's like I really needed that and he's
just like you know what I had tickets
for us I spent this with that and he
looks over and there's $200 on the on
the nightstand and then he just pulls
the he pulls the covers up on himself
he's like call me and it's just like you
didn't expect Murphy to do that you
didn't expect Murphy to Murphy Murphy
was all I always thought that Murphy was
a hell of a better actor than he was
ever given credit for yeah me too
yeah always dumb looking bangin up when
you watch him in Nutty Professor he
knows what it is to be a fat guy
but I liked him and [ __ ] still 40 now
woody that was had trade in place as I
strum but I yeah and we're coming up on
it
the thing about boomerang was why like
boomerang is when this movie came out I
wasn't that dumps yeah my personal life
was [ __ ] shredded I had this little
white girl I was in love with she moved
to New York City and [ __ ] I was in
Boulder all alone I was doing stand-up
twice a week I was seeing valiums I was
snorting blow yeah I was just long way
in high schooler video store and rent
movies every day like an [ __ ] watch
one movie and wouldn't stand up Seattle
and write notes from the stand-up
special about what I like about that
style we're studying it yeah and I watch
boomer in and I went off the charts that
scene with Chris Rock just a bunch of
Samoan bang they just have 15 great
scenes and then will be that I think
it's agenda that a lot of people want
I like those movies when I get surprised
yeah when I'm [ __ ] and shocked like
how good the movie there's a lot of
movies that you watch that the first I
would take you in that direction like
[ __ ] I'm on to something here but then
you're like [ __ ] they gave me such a
disappointment like the last three
Johnny Depp movies like the [ __ ] one
about dark shadows
of great it was a great first ow the war
with Janeiro the family mm-hmm I watched
the first hour that I'm ready to go they
loved it I loved the whole village it's
the [ __ ] girl on that the young girl
all the daughters great a daughter is
[ __ ] and the son makes me laugh I saw
this grant
listen ugly movies that you see that
you're like Jesus there's a little hope
no no something so much more from black
mass speaking of Johnny Depp oh yeah but
I thought that a bolter yeah I was
hoping for a lot more from that know
what man I thought the movie was well
done I thought he was acting was great
I think the sale of the gangster anymore
that whole appearance sister Sopranos
it just got why please change again you
know it changed the game so that's why
Whitey Bulger we all know about him like
that releasing Gotti the son oh yeah
Travolta Travolta where you can have
fillers do at Travolta's done I mean
it's not your fault always comes back
but it did he was great on that Oh Jason
but I don't think you anything in my
journey or anything in my John Gotti
okay oh I'd love to make you pay $12 on
the Friday and go get two tickets and go
watch it no you know people a few people
took the time
look the the era of one that is being
set it's too close to Goodfellas and
Goodfellas the greatest ever made what's
a movie you like with Jim cash what's
the best movie Jim Carrey Jim Carrey
ever did yeah oh the [ __ ] brother
when they go on the mission to Aspen to
go get the girl
I thought dumb and dumber yeah doing
dumb dumb and dumber he could have done
three sequels Dumb and Dumber was such a
great movie you would have paid 20 for
the [ __ ] sequel but he told you to go
[ __ ] themselves then they released it 20
years later what happened they went in a
chair three people want to see it his
guess what normally Ramona get a buck
anymore we wanted it a year after you
release that we would have gone twice
and to see it yeah that's how much we
wanted that second one you know its
timing everything is really timing with
what's going on and
the problem with that is always you know
a comic wants to prove that he's got
dramatic chops he doesn't want to be
dismissed as just a funny guy
because it's not respected when comics
should really embrace how hard it is to
make somebody laugh nobody you know what
a lot of people can do those dramatic
roles I don't know of an actor working
today who could do easy money there's
not a [ __ ] actor who could go in and
make you believe that he's Rodney
drinking drugging gambling and and
taking baby pictures in the morning who
could do that they'd die that the one
guy there's one guy that can do it if
anybody could do it there's only one guy
like it was that the guy that played the
brother in the boxing movie with Marky
Wahlberg
bail Christian Bale cuz she'll be able
to play that guy and make it funny they
can do anything okay I'll give you that
movie you came to me and you said dog I
got to write from Rodney's wife and
you're really just move it yeah the
pottage the bartender's going to Joey
Diaz were they insulted mm-hmm I just
want that he's my guy I just want that
saying this is why that's why it stinks
like [ __ ] in here you want that guy no I
want the other guy oh the guy who closes
his bar yeah what we're gonna do today
oh no oh no oh no no no a horse in the
night believe me
really he looks so as a guy at the ball
past that he reaches the register the
money baggage let's go oh my god there's
your dollar we're closing up today we're
going for the track anybody who owns a
business would not you know all those
scenes yeah took me back like I had just
lived through that yeah like I was
living in Snowmass Village I'm lonely as
[ __ ] I'm there and easy money comes out
and that's what I just went through
wages what we're gonna do tonight
well Lee needs to go here with me the
only way to do that I gotta go this by
this
my mother when she needed tomorrow guess
what get the [ __ ] cop gonna track
down there that's turkey sandwiches on
the way I can't I told my father and had
to call my father tell your father
you're in my a it so I would take in the
car telling me with me and Ramos that's
how life was yeah and that's how they
live it and then we would go Tina
where's your father he's taking baby
pictures what type of baby is up at nine
o'clock I'd like and they switched him
being a strip club him straight up look
at the girls tits you know that they
don't even think that that would have so
people today you know the [ __ ]
opening where he's taking baby pictures
like Lovejoy and falls out will be even
before that who's the baby who's the
baby here is like how old are you I'm
this yeah well tell call me when you're
this you would never get away with that
like every time I show that these people
they lose their [ __ ] yeah but it's what
day does your punches get drunk ah I'm
going home balancing everything and
putting it tonight
so what days is a usual it'll drop well
Wednesday sees every Wednesday what's
them yeah watch this with Rick Rommel
iTunes it's on iTunes it's on soundcloud
listen if you want to really know about
movies and actors and directors and
timepieces know where the movie was made
and how it was made in the budget this
is the [ __ ] guy all right I wouldn't
put him on here this I'm sorry we didn't
going to move you know what happened
I'll be going to movies this would be
like a [ __ ] Dave Chapelle show this
will be a nine-hour podcast my friend
has [ __ ] to do please do time for us to
leave he's got a yum-yum donut hidden
somewhere I could tell he bought three
young young dollars in the chocolate
shop
he knew deep tonight
so he's like only got three onion donuts
from this nights I sit here with him and
I could tell him he's my brother he
loves me I love being around them but I
told you guys leave he and me and him a
sitting here at one point where he just
gives me this I like it's time for you
to leave I know that if I come back I'm
gonna catch him with a big sandwich yeah
I know it's like he's got it
Mike under a chair somewhere around here
there's a burrito that smothered because
he gets angry at me for like we thought
might um some I think yeah it's a great
idea I call me Mom
like he throws me up because there's
something hidden around this somebody's
car if I even eat food in here like six
hours I know you can smell it no I can't
smell it because I'm not coming back
you're thinking outside like a
professional oh you sure I love you
[ __ ] I'll see you Tuesday I'll
see you Friday and Saturday that's a New
York Comedy Club you know I love you
[ __ ] and I'll also see you next
Tuesday at The Comedy Store and you also
how about the night before Thanksgiving
that they're invited improv that's how
we're doing it [ __ ] but don't
forget one thing and you don't mean I've
been working with these guys for a long
time why because it's a great product
number two they give you a risk-free 60
day guarantee and number three I believe
in the thought listen I'm no Harvey one
saying but from time to time
I wish you'd naked lady fell out of the
sky implant yeah I have the hungers in
his eyes everybody else wants decent so
he lands on your naked and she stinks
like a billy goat what good is it
you just gonna push her aside there's no
hose in the middle of Broadway that's
why I believe in this product that won't
everybody's monkey to be fresh I want
your [ __ ] to be fresh that's tough
I'm a chubby guy I gotta watch that more
for three to four or five times a day
some people take a poop they wipe their
ass they walk around I take a poop I go
right into the shower there's no need to
wipe because the owners are unrestrained
will down there you understand me but I
know this is going in because I'm a
professional [ __ ] Savage it's not
like I just came here I took a shower
you know just gonna sit here and sweat
my ass up because I believe in ass and
the monkey and sling and dick hygiene
that's why I believe in touchy
Thanksgiving is the time to express your
gratitude and recollect I want you truly
grateful for but
listen you know what you're grateful for
people come over your house they watch
your TV
they eat the appetizers and then right
after to Turkey they blow up your
[ __ ] bathroom you go in there it
looks like not the sake there's blood
there's towels the soaps [ __ ] up
it smells like candles on top of candles
on top of Lysol on top by eight
different different shits even the
bathroom there's a hand coming out with
a white flag like it's hot as [ __ ] like
this but the best thing is you don't
want your grandma will see you walking
around with a gravy but because all she
had was a flimsy toilet paper to wipe
with her she will wash away all the mash
[ __ ] potatoes and all the mildew that
lasts around the muffler me I had a
loofah
before I had a loof I cut it down and I
wrapped my finger there and I would
circle around my muffler to clean off
the mildew but now I don't need to do
that because I won't have those mashed
potatoes with the gentle stream of water
straight to my butt giving it the best
clean that's ever had I mean you want to
leave with leftovers but not hanging
with [ __ ] their [ __ ] so make sure
you're ready for the holiday bum rush
with tushie stop wiping with that
[ __ ] nasty toilet paper and get on
the holiday bun brush okay you know why
you want to walk around with a clean ass
so hello Lucy calm that's the way to go
again you like Joey where do I get these
[ __ ] bidets hello pushy calm
60-day money-back guarantee I'm gonna
take care of you
I got a cushy birthday for $69 with a
risk-free 60-day trial all right plus if
you're gonna help Tricia calm and use
the code Church I'm gonna give you 10%
off
now who's Melanie uncle Joey you gotta
feel more confident and your [ __ ]
gonna stink truckin tremendous okay
who's better than you who's gonna Santa
Claus when I go do you got a stinky ass
Santa Claus ain't coming over you
understand me so gonna hello tisha calm
right now and use the code Church right
now to get 10% off your coffee and it's
not only that it's not stinky if you
fresh it feels it's amazing really I
have a cold one
and I love it I love it I don't take a
[ __ ] unless that sometimes I'm gonna
roll I think I take a [ __ ] I hold it you
could take it off yeah but then I got a
[ __ ] fix in what if I break it I
don't take that chance
that's my personal [ __ ] tushy and
we've had it for what we're overweight
that that thing is [ __ ] washed our
ass and worked how long is it gonna last
go to hell old [ __ ] dot-com right now
it's [ __ ] tremendous I want to thank
my man Rick Ramos what's the name of the
podcast watch this for the requirements
and I want to thank my little
[ __ ] Lisa at hello is being my
partner in crime and there's yong-chol
Joe if I don't see it as we go I'm sorry
it took it sold out but if you live in
the LA area I'll see you Tuesday night
in the original room right thank you
very much for listening I want to thank
Rick Ramos have a great weekend
stay black uncle Joey loves you that's
it